the US has announced we will be
deploying more troops to the Middle East
we've already got a large uh a large
amount 19,000 Personnel already in the
Mediterranean we've got another 2,000
marines that are poised poised to go and
the Pentagon is saying 900 more troops
have already deployed are or are
deploying so I hope youall are ready for
what's to come Israel previously agreed
to delay their invasion of Gaza to allow
the US to prepare missile batteries
Patriot missile uh Patriot missile and
Thad missile systems and now we've got
reporting Israel has invaded Gaza so I
hope you're ready for what comes next
now interestingly the official reporting
is saying no no they have not yet
invaded Gaza they've just sent a bunch
of tanks in to start targeting Hamas tar
targets and killing Hamas Leaders with
tanks in Gaza so so the tanks are going
in but it's not an invasion and I'm just
like yo if having a bunch of Tanks go
into this territory and kill people is
not an invasion then what's happening on
the southern border is not an invasion
okay yeah this is what's happening but
they're trying to be careful about what
they call it for for PR reasons people
are probably going to get really mad
about that we'll talk about that plus we
got a bunch more uh news as of right now
police have surrounded the suspect in
the main shooting they've surrounded the
home they've announced come out this is
all developing so we'll we'll give this
a a little time to see what what's going
on with this story and then new video of
Jamal Bowman Oh Boy the video shows him
intentionally removing the warning signs
from the door pulling the fire alarm and
running away yeah this is much more than
just a accidentally pulled the fire
alarm now he's already pleaded guilty
but it looks like the the actions he's
taken appear to be more felony territory
than anything we'll get into that before
we get started head over to cast
brew.com and buy cast brew coffee why
it's best coffee you're ever going to
have no question we got the limited
edition rise with Roberto Jr it's
Halloween and we are I guess callously
mocking the death of our own rooster and
mascot but you know it's Halloween so by
Rise with Roberto Jr it's a medium roast
it's actually really good one of my
favorites and uh we support ourselves
Cas brew coffee is our coffee brand we
are launching coffee shops if you want
to help us build these physical
locations and be a part of the movement
then go to cbw buy your coffee from us
but don't forget to also go to timcast
click join us become a member if you
want to just support our work directly
this company is funded by viewers like
you if you like the work we do and you
want to see more of it click join us and
you'll also get access to our members
only uncensored shows we're going to
have an uncensored show tonight at 10
p.m. you don't want to miss it because
we're taking your phone calls that's
right as a member you get access to our
Discord server to hang out with
like-minded individuals but also submit
questions and call into the show and
talk to us and our guests going to be a
lot of fun so smash that like button
share the show right now if you really
do like it joining us tonight to talk
about this and a whole lot more is Grace
Chung hi thanks for having me I'm so
happy to be here I'm the CEO and CFO of
Steve bannon's war room and I've had
quite a journey to get here I used to be
in the film industry and believe it or
not I met Steve Bannon 20 years ago at
my very first job in the film industry
wow yes and so now I've I'm working for
him directly for the war room and it's
just been it's been really great I mean
I wear a ton of different hats I'm you
know one minute I'm doing um Financial
strategies the next I'm pushing content
out on um all social media the next I'm
all of a sudden in New York doing a
grand jury and uh you know also doing uh
creating some cool ideas for our merch
right here War yes yeah uh we just
dropped a new line if you go to um if I
can do a plug um shop warroom.com we''ve
got sweatshirts beanies which we're
going to send you some oh wow and um
we've got uh totes and a women's line so
for everyone you know your audience and
also the waren posy love you guys shout
out to all the waren posy that's
supporting uh we have a discount code
for 20% off timcast 20
the website's live now so go you can go
for it and also we have another special
announcement if I can um say it right
now is we developed an app it's actually
for um the posi but really anyone that
wants to get engaged you know especially
with what happened with the speaker
election of calling all your
representatives and congressmen and
right now it's just been so difficult
because you have a general online and
you have to like talk to a switchboard
but we created an app where it's a list
of all your representatives your
Senators based on your location if you
want to take uh turn off the location
part you can look up any state any
representative and it's all in one app
you can also click on their website to
email them and this is just another tool
for us to just really hound them and to
make sure that um the representative
here their
constituents and did you say the name of
it yet oh it's called Bill Blaster it
right now it is only available on Apple
it was a passion project that was
created by myself and my friend who will
M remain nameless cuz he's in the tech
industry and you know the whole caner
culture thing but um but this is just a
tool because it actually started when
the Deb ceiling Steve Steve banon my
boss he wanted me to like put all these
lists together of who voted yes and no
and it just became this whole Excel
spreadsheet I love Excel cuz I'm you
know in accounting and finance and then
um it ended up being like a 40 page PDF
of like people all like I had their
Twitter handles or X handles their their
websites and everything and um you know
my my really pissed off techy
friend he he was like let's make an app
let's not go backwards on let's take
action let's action action action so
we've been working on this for months
and yeah just build Blaster it's
available on Apple we're going to work
on the Android soon um but please
download it it's free and and yeah it's
it's a great tool and I'm super excited
right on well thanks thanks for hang out
it should be fun we got Hannah Clair
hanging out hi I'm Hannah Clair brimo
I'm a writer for
timcast.net
what's up I'm uh Shane Cashman a big fan
of war room I was reporting in East
Palestine and I chased a guy who was in
a screaming match at the uh local uh
authorities there and I when I followed
him I wound up at a bar and in that bar
I looked over his shoulder and Steve
Bannon was there and I was like hey it's
nice to see some other people reporting
on that town that people have forgotten
about but I write books I write the
inverted World Series and uh if you're
feeling in the Halloween mood got the
inverted world book from this recent
year uh publish it early this year in
February or March and that's me looking
for confederate gold getting threatened
by men who are dating a coven of witches
and uh get into UFOs right on and I'm
surge.com just want to tell you guys to
cheer for South Africa against England
uh in the upcoming finals of the rug
World Cup uh and that's all Tim we're
never ready all right here's the story
from CNN Pentagon says 900 US troops
have deployed or are deploying to Middle
East amid height and tension so just a
few days out from Halloween and we have
not even prepared our Halloween party
but uh don't worry we don't need much
all we'll have to do is put on CNN and a
bunch of other news outlets and just
have them run continuous news coverage
of how the US is about to enter a
massive regional conflict which could
bleed out into World War III the one
thing I can say is that where uh uh
whereas this is getting crazy what's
going on in the Middle East it seems
like Ukraine's dying down yeah what's
that you know so uh maybe Linsky will
tell you all about it do not worry maybe
it won't be World War III because
everyone kind of forgot Ukraine's
happening
and uh that's you know gone but at the
same time as we're seeing these
deployments we have this from uh this is
the guardian is also talking about us
deployment but uh we have this from Fox
News Israeli forces conduct tank raid in
Gaza ahead of expected Invasion I am not
going to play these stupid double speak
games with you you do not have video
even of Tanks storming through the
border and killing people and blowing
things up and say we didn't invade yet
that's quite quite literally you invaded
now they're trying to make this
distinction likely because they want to
downplay their actions and we know when
the word gets out it's not like the any
foreign country cares about what we call
it this is for the American people they
don't want the American people to hear
Israel has invaded Gaza US deploys
troops to the region so they say no no
no there's no Invasion yet just a tank
raid just going for a walk you know they
they need to stretch their legs test out
their wheels so you know it's not a big
deal an invasion stop asking us
questions an incursion they know once
the American people hear words like
World War III there's no coming back and
then I think the media is afraid to
Define it as such although I also think
they want it I think a lot of people in
media do want this war they need they
need their Cassis belly before the
escalation if World War III keeps
getting repeated over and over again and
we hear about troop deployments and
there's no justification for it people
are going to reject it it's going to
Poison the Well so that's why they got
to downplay the language and make it
seem like no nothing's happening it's
just you know things are getting tense
then when US forces are attacked or
there's some kind of terror attack or
something happens they can then say now
we've invaded do you think to a certain
extent they also want to normalize it
they want people in in the US to think
oh well our troops are already there of
course they're there they had to be look
Syria does anybody remember the point at
which we entered Syria and started
building military bases no but then they
run the headline American Military Base
bombed or whatever it was all all of a
sudden Donald Trump's like oh yeah we've
had troops in Syria we're getting them
out we're like wait what really we were
there yeah we were there yeah we're
getting our troops out and they lied
about that too they don't want the
American people to know this is the
craziest thing that there are Secret
Wars going on and this is 10 years ago
what was going on in Yemen was described
as a secret War the American people did
not know what was happening and it's
still happening and now Syria and all
these countries I think I wonder if they
they realized hey we we don't need to
generate public support if we just don't
tell them it's happening yeah yeah you
know just don't write it no no no once
you just tell them we're already doing
it people expect that it's normal right
if they're used to seeing the headlines
they don't care and that's what I think
is the most frustrating thing about the
24-hour news cycle it's not that we
don't need to have it of course with the
internet you have to keep up on the
other hand everything becomes
information overload so you're used to
seeing uh American troops in places that
you didn't expect them because you by
the time you wake up in the morning 45
stories have been written about it
there's no way to just say like oh wait
y yeah when I walked in the room just
now and I asked you guys what are we
starting with i' had been on another
show for an hour and I you know the
world can change in that hour and you
like oh we've in the Israel's invaded
gods are like oh wow you know and that's
how I feel when I fly now I get in an
airplane I'm afraid to come down you
know I'm like what will the world look
like when I land um well I mean the
internet on airplanes is pretty good
these days I never get it I actually I
never get Wi-Fi on the airplane well you
know you get why not I get work I get
work done I get I get to write yeah I do
two I have two loud kids and I get I get
it's my office face up in the air but
yeah I mean when I'm flying that's I'm
online that's what I do tracking the
news you know yeah I'm a cave man I kind
of sometimes it's nice to be able to
plug in like when we were flying to
Miami I was uh transcribing an interview
I had done and that way I couldn't open
four or five tabs you know what I mean
cuz it'sing I'm 100 years old Tim what
can I say no it's just like the worst
job ever the worst thing but I like
occasionally there's things that you're
thinking if I just buckle down and do
this it will be great but the mainstream
media does I mean and the same thing
with social media right they need you to
constantly be checking your apps they
need you to want the notifications they
need you to be hooked up to the dopamine
and in some ways the way this news cycle
is working I'm sure everyone can point
to something this it reminds me a lot of
the beginning of coid right every 5
Seconds their business model right
you're checking constantly for updates
on where you're allowed to go do you
remember that during Co we had there
were states where you couldn't travel
from another state that was such a
bizarre time and so you were constantly
looking for new information w't there
checkpoints between New York and
Connecticut yeah that's crazy does he
like full test to go to Hawaii lot of
test that woman who got arrested because
she flew to Hawaii and then filmed
herself like walking around and they
were like you didn't quarantine and get
tested and stuff they almost didn't let
me in the room to see my daughter be
born I had to handcuff myself almost to
my wife this was one of my opening
stories to Shane he was like yeah I
brought handcuffs and I wasn't going to
go anywhere I was going to handcuff
myself to the bed there no way they were
yeah I was ready wow dude I'm and then
she was the only one who had to get your
wife was the only one to get Co tested
in the room oh yeah and I had a governor
who was a mass uh murderer uh we can get
into that later but speaking about
speaking about like the news and missing
it for an hour like last time I was on
IRL last last week it was when the
hospital was supposedly bombed right oh
yeah within that first hour there were
multiple realities about that or last
night I'm watching the main thing on
fold with the shooter and there's people
sharing multiple videos that aren't true
or pictures of people that aren't the
suspect so it's almost like it doesn't
matter what happens in hour because in
that first hour of news breaking there's
a distortion of of all this noise and no
one knows the truth and probably for the
next few weeks too until we know more
sometimes I like the first hour after a
story has broken because just the bare
minimum details are coming out and it
gives you something to build off of
Because by the time the identity of
whoever is involved or the the total
numbers of death or these kind of tragic
details that are incredibly important to
report accuracy by the time those are
out there's already a slant and you can
see the way it's being bent it's funny
cuz I typically say I when I was
teaching journalism I like to tell the
students you know your your best source
for information is the stuff that's
closest to the event so like in Maine
you know it's who's there thinking of
what's going on in in Gaza and Israel
there's a lot of people on that ground
who are manipulating news as well and
they're right there so you got to be so
careful you know I keep urging people to
not just believe anything that instantly
confirms any bias you have towards
anything domestic or foreign because if
it makes you feel good you should
probably be extra suspicious of that
news I saw tun of conservative
commentators retweeting a bunch of fake
videos uhhuh all the time it's happened
a lot I mean yesterday with the the the
shooter in Maine oh yeah yeah I saw I
was like yo what are you guys doing man
but it's that that urgency especially uh
Twitter whatever it's called has really
emphasized this more than ever that you
have to be the first or one of the
beginning people to to share it to
repost it you know you need to be on the
front lines of everything and it means
that if you wait to verify you're behind
but actually you know the truth it's
this sort of weird weird uh issue with
what you're saying with the
international component of what's being
reported on the ground I always find
that the language barrier is sort of the
biggest obstacle because you know I
don't speak either of the languages for
which the main resources the I'm just uh
not that educated you know I I just uh I
really like English I'm still trying to
master it every day as a struggle no I'm
just kidding but uh unless you're Chris
car and you see all my typos but uh the
the issue there is that people who can
speak those languages and I don't mean
this in a mean way have their own bias
when they read the news and so when they
are reading their own sources I mean
especially if you're you know let's say
an immigrant from one of these places in
America you have ties there it makes it
not that they couldn't do it accurately
I don't want to make any accusations but
it just means it's there's a layer of
emotional um there's a layer of emotion
there there two barriers you're talking
about and there's like the barrier we
have to deal with here uh in other
English speaking countries where it's
like the the barrier of bias and the
words they use to describe certain
people and the qualifiers they might use
in terms of like when New York Times
writes about RFK Jr all the qualifiers I
got to put in front of his name he's a
you know coid conspiracy theorist all
these things but then it's also the
language barrier on top of that when
you're dealing with the international
news so it makes it to the point where
I'm like I can't really believe anything
I'm reading right now and everyone just
wants to go viral oh yeah make whether
true or not or somewhat true yeah and
then they won't delete it because they
should uh yeah Elon should get rid of
well I say he should but uh Twitter had
talked about getting rid of follower
counts and like retweet numbers and
stuff like this and uh the reason they
never did Twitter knew that it's a
scoring system status ratio means you
failed and retweets mean you've
succeeded and that's that's what
everyone does on on x yeah if you got
rid of that you lose the gamification of
social media and nobody wants to give up
that position but then the sorry the
Bots subverted that though like just
today uh our friends in myth informed
right uh they were locked out of their
account I retweeted something about them
I happened to tag ex support or whatever
infiltrated by Bots a dozen dozens of of
accounts all created in October of this
year sharing the same link different you
know Bots but are those Bots they're
they have the blue check right I don't
know if they all have the blue check but
their names were all was like a name and
then like a bunch of numbers next to it
and then the same link so they they will
have a lot of those Bots will now have
those blue checks yeah Instagram tried
something similar where they removed
they would say we'll take away the the
like number like how many likes your
photo is getting and at the time they
were saying it was to combat especially
uh you know social media addiction but
specifically um body dysmorphia issues
with young teenage girls uh the fact
that they would you know post certain
things and they would get a reaction to
it uh and I don't know that it made a
difference I think in some ways it it
just re-emphasize that you don't know
how valued you are and I don't like that
we have these digits on the other hand
you can understand when we have the
content uh the the influencer industry
that says we need to know how many
people follow you we need to know what
your reach is like we need to know what
your engagement is like why those tools
actually exist for some people as a
business model yeah I want to I want to
pull up this tweet from kit Claren BG
kit is a reporter for I I I believe he's
at grey Zone and he noticed something
interesting now I want to make sure I'm
very careful here as we start this this
is not hard confirmation of anything but
I do think it's something that Warren's
paying attention to he stated it's over
and there's an article that says Israel
rejects zelinsky's visit time is not
right and this is from 10 days ago he
says what's also striking is prominent
Pro Ukraine accounts are shuttering
rapidly such as UA weapons which claimed
to track Russian losses and garnered
almost a million followers wonder how
long it'll take for those flags start
disappearing from display names display
names why do you think asks H2 he say
says infrastructure technology and
Personnel used to amplify these accounts
as being redirected elsewhere Western
Powers have no use of propaganda
encouraging The View Ukraine will win
and needs to be sent weapons now quite
the opposite so this is an interesting
uh argument that we're seeing I think we
have uh this one he says absolutely
classic an anonymous high-profile Pro
Ukraine account that 10 days ago
attacked me for suggesting high profile
Pro Ukraine accounts are shutting down
in a coordinated manner is now shutting
down calibra of skura says I will be
deleting this account within a few weeks
life is increasingly busy and frankly no
longer in a place where I want to
interact with things that I do every day
etc etc now it may be this is very very
interesting this is a tweet from October
16th when he put this out this is this
this a little while ago uh that he
tweeted this and then I think this uh
this next one was from just uh just
yesterday it could be that uh us
intelligence agencies have been running
scops Pro Ukraine accounts generating
massive numbers of followers not
necessarily Pro Ukraine like this UA uh
uh weapons uh uh account apparently was
tracking all information but the
argument would be yes but from a western
perspective when they say oh Russian
troops are dying it's is it the Western
number or the Russian number and then
you have this other account that's sh
shuttering as well perhaps one of two
things is happening and there could be
other things Intel agencies are running
scops and now that the money is being
diverted to Israel in the Middle
East we can't run these accounts anymore
so somebody who is in you know some kind
of division or private contractor is
told hey shutter those accounts we're
going to be focusing on Israel and they
go you got it oh sorry my family thing
happened or The Simple Solution perhaps
is Ukraine is over no one cares anymore
these look this this one account calibra
being like you know my life's getting a
little busy you might as well just say
what is going on in Ukraine no longer
Bears weight with me and other things
have become more important
and that just says whether it is the end
of a scop or not nobody cares about
Ukraine it's done yeah I mean it's not
good for zalinski either way he uh he
was really counting on more American
money from what I understand uh but I
think it's interesting I said this
before Russia won yeah I think in a lot
of ways that's true I think it's
interesting to see um the way Ukraine
has fallen to the background right I
mean we don't see any pro Ukraine
protests it's not even like there was a
way for these two different groups to
team up it's just off record and to a
certain extent I credit that to the fact
that the American people can really only
have one big thing in the news cycle at
a time it's very difficult for them to
have you know hold hold pay attention to
two things at once yeah it's like that
Meme where they insert one brain trip of
Ukraine then the next one is of Israel
yeah Israel yeah I mean that's like the
capacity that that they can really just
go off of if it is a
scop man I got a roote Awakening we got
a roote Awakening for these Intel
agencies it's like all of the stuff
that's been happening with the
manipulation on social media that's uh
uh propped up woke left Psy psychotic
garbage how how do they expect to get
military support for Israel when they
have themselves coordinated with these
big Tech platforms to prop up
anti-israel
sentiment I don't know I'm saying like
they're incompetent unless it really is
some deep 5D chess where they're like
first we make them ha Israel then we
make them like Israel and like I really
doubt it I think the people who are just
running this propaganda are just really
dumb I wish they could Rebrand these
scops into something positive and caring
about places like East Palestine or or
Maui you know but they won't do that I
don't know that's always my question
like like are they just incompetent or
are they just evil like I just cannot I
don't think they make money off these
pal the way they do with this yeah for
sure and I think I think that's evil
taking advantage of a lot of incompetent
people right you know and I think there
is a SC up component to these things and
there's obviously also organic people
who latched on to the SC up like maybe
this person who says you know I'm moving
on to other things is a real person we
went to this Tois restaurant called
Barcelona Barcelona in uh in Reston
Virginia it was awesome by the way we've
been there like three weeks in a row
because it's so good bar Barcelona
Barcelona that's how they say it in
Barcelona but uh Barcelona is the name
of the restaurant and uh that we have
fans who uh who work there and um I mean
maybe they won't like that I'm saying I
don't know but the people they were
completely open like oh hey you know
like we're big fans nice to meet you and
then we went back and this guy came up
and said he's like hey man I love your
show you're probably not going to get
that out here in Reston but I'm a big
fan keep it up and I was like actually
we've had like four or five people here
shout us out I think the reason I bring
that out I'm not trying to Humble bre or
anything the the point is stop thinking
you're alone everyone thinks they're the
only one they're sitting there being
like Oh that's Tim pool I watch him I
know no one else does so I better just
say it quietly no no it turns out
everybody there was super cool so too
many people are seeing these scops
seeing the manipulation on social media
and they're assuming wow everyone in
this country must secretly like trans
kids and Ukraine war and stuff I better
keep my mouth shut then it turns out
everyone actually agrees with you nobody
likes us wasting money on these Foreign
Wars there's been no justification for
why we're doing it shifting from Ukraine
to the Middle East now mhm so if people
just start realizing that starts
speaking up maybe we can put a stop to
it this is why I advocate for parents
when they go on play dates to
immediately open up the conversation
about all the things you care about the
most so you can Whittle down who you can
have your kids hang out with or not I
think you should screen all your kids
friends that does make sense to me I got
an idea I got an idea here's what we do
an app where you can select things that
you believe in politically and then with
your friends it will only show your
political positions if you agree it's
like public for I'm going to tell my uh
developer friend did you get that so
like it'll say what's your stance on on
pro pro pro-choice pro-life Progressive
taxes border control and then if you
don't agree on anything it just doesn't
share anything and yeah dating app sort
of for it's like bumble bumble had they
had Bumble BFF which is like for women
to meet other women and friends I'm not
actually serious for the most part
because like you can't Implement
something like this but the general idea
is you know you could you could input
your your political uh uh you know views
and then you don't have to worry about
someone being like ah you know but that
the reality is you should just be able
to say Hey you know I don't like the
fact that in New York they're
threatening Jewish people right now
maybe they shouldn't do that I think
you're probably just not as weird as you
think you are I mean I think a lot of
people feel like because they're not
hearing it on mainstream media maybe
other people don't want to talk about it
but or just afraid to say it out loud
yeah right probably your views are not
that outlandish you're probably not that
dramatic of a person like you just
believe the things you believe and if
you treat it like it's normal which it
is other people will fall suit even if
they don't completely agree with you so
like when I say clouds are fake fake
it's fine well it gives us something to
talk about right how are we going to get
to know how people feel about this
important is fake uh I think the
majority of clouds are fake
yes I think they've been pumped into the
atmosphere or or created out of
chemtrails and they just get recycled
and it's just poison falling out of the
sky I think it's just water vapor well I
think a lot of them or I think some of
them are water how you build an
intellectual conversation about these
differing viewpoints I I think we've
poisoned our Sky to
such uh I think we've Cloud seed so much
that it's hard to tell yeah but they use
lasers for cloud now oh man yeah they
don't need to put chemicals up there
maybe but I'm talk maybe it's the
Vintage clouds you know they haven't
really got they're still in the cycle
see the thing is I don't have a position
on cloud so this is very helpful to help
me to think learn about this topic no
look it up look it up this is good we've
been seting clouds for a while um but
we're doing different ways now more
silver iodide was the first way they did
it and then they started using um I
think 10 years ago infrared lasers
lasers to Cloud C must be wild when you
go on playdates with your kids like how
what you launch into it's just like this
what's your view on clouds also our kids
don't eat sugar exactly or or Salmon's
Salmon's bioengineered and part bug so
don't eat that either well also people
don't realize that a lot of salmon when
it says wild CAU they grow it in a farm
release it into the wild and then
recatch it no joke wait so wild CAU it
can be a lie wait so then which one do
you get which one do you get cuz it's
not so a there's things you got to watch
out for are if there's a company called
like wild cot salmon and wild cot is a
brand name m that's Farm or if it wild
CAU salmon is brand name is not mad I'm
not I'm not saying quite literally
that's the case I'm saying watch out for
brand names that masquerade as and look
for the colors of salmon too yeah yeah
uh if you look online you'll notice that
wild Salmon's actually not so fatty so
if your salmon is pretty fatty it's
probably corn fed or something nonsense
but what they'll do is they'll raise
salmon in a farm in a big vat then
they'll dump them in the ocean then
they'll go with big ships and catch them
and say we caught them in the wild yeah
Fukushima is problem to recap uh Salmons
don't like corn they're not a corn on a
c the cop fan I I think they feed them
corn not entirely sure but uh more back
to the point the the point I was
bringing up initially is that with this
story uh uh potentially arguing that
many of these Pro Ukraine accounts were
scops the first thing I'd have to say
outside of you know the the context of
the story just in general is absolutely
the government is running psychological
operations on social media to generate
support for war yes so think about all
the accounts right now that are
demanding us intervention over Israel
and Elon Musk says he wants to charge a
dollar per year it's the only way to get
rid of the
Bots I don't know if even that will will
work all he's going to do is create a
more expensive market for Bots yep right
now Bots are free you charge a dollar
what's going to happen is the barrier
for entry for bot making goes up and
then the bot companies and contractors
will just say so you wanted how many
Bots 3,000 H we're increasing our prices
by
340% uh because of Elon muss you know
dollar so you got to cover the dollar
per account then you've got to cover the
credit card you know so it's an extra 15
bucks all in all it's going to cost you
three or four times more for your Bots
and and then these these organizations
go oh yeah no problem I can afford that
it becomes a business expense it's just
more expensive to do right and you think
like governments are going to abandon
their scops on Twitter no no they've
been working on those for a long time no
they love psychological operations
they've been performing them on us for
forever so he's a SC up within a SC up
within a s up yeah yep that's exactly it
yeah you don't know maybe the SC up was
the SC up the whole time maybe the SC up
was the S up we made along the way
getting getting the S up to be exposed
was the actual
intention wow again chest that I can't
is inverted World season 3 off I go it
is kind of hilarious that uh you know a
few weeks ago we were talking about how
the I'm looking at the
BBC's battle map for Ukraine and it
shows Russia controlling the land bridge
into Crimea and I'm like that's it they
got what they wanted and I'm these
conservatives are like that's not true
they wanted all of Ukraine they were
going to invade from the north and now
all of a sudden it's like okay we lost
we're done everybody out mhm we're uh
we're no longer interested in what's
going on in Ukraine again I'd really
like to uh hear more from zalinski who
is probably so mad about his business
venture failing uh I I do think you know
we couldn't sustain this even with Janet
Yellen saying we can afford two Wars
realistically no and also we could maybe
theoretically continue to pay for both
things I know uh speaker Johnson was
sort of there was a clip of him being
asked by journalists are you going to
send more money to Ukraine today but the
reality is as much as we need financial
it needs it needs the attention span of
the American people right and if it's
not there the money won't follow they
could print all the money they want but
it's the morale they need I want to jump
to this Twitter thread from Jeff Morris
Jr at jmj he's managing partner at
chapter 1 and he writes at the new
internet former VP of product at Tinder
VP of product and revenue he says the
Tik Tock War why high school and college
kids are getting the wrong information
about Hamas and Israel he said I spent
the weekend trying to reverse engine the
Tik Tok algorithm is I am convinced this
is the reason we are losing the
information war with high school and
college students one red flag was seeing
San Francisco high school students who
were aggressively anti-israel and asking
myself where they were getting their
news their protests happened right after
the fake New York Times headline that
accused Israel of the hospital bomb I
also want to pause real quick uh as well
the Wall Street Journal maintains that
the video we see of the rocket exploding
in midair and payload falling was what
hit the parking lot the New York Times
got the story wrong apologized and then
came out with another story like
actually that video you watch was wrong
our analysis says that's actually and I
would hit the hospital and it's like
very convenient for the New York Times
who flubbed this one really really bad
to be like actually we weren't that
wrong so I think the New York Times is
full of it I think the New York Times is
a captured organization that is
desperately trying to be Pro Hamas we
saw this with the Tom Cotton uh uh oped
the oped editor got fired because Tom
Cotton wrote an opet about bringing the
sending the military because of the BLM
riots so New York Times you know for a
long time look what Barry Weiss had to
say it is a captured leftist institution
let's read he says the bigger red flag
was seeing 51% of Americans aged 18 to
24 believe Hamas terrorists who raped
and murdered innocent women and children
believe Hamas was
justified my high school classmates who
lived through 911 would never believe
this that's right look at this you guys
seen this this this uh chart he's uh uh
this this graph is actually missing one
other important component not only do 18
to 24 year olds in the majority believe
it was justified but in the majority
believe it was
genocide I believe it's 60 uh was it
63% of uh 18 to 24 year olds believe
what Hamas did was genocide and 51%
believe it is Justified mhm that is
insane W let's read more he says why do
high school students in San Francisco
hate Israel so much I'd assume very few
of them have been to Israel let alone
have a fully formed view of a
multigenerational conflict they're 16
years old and live in California let's
be serious from minut really for Gen Z
Tik Tok is the new search engine it's
the number one search engine for more
than half of gen Z it's the primary news
source for many younger demos and while
we have justifiable concerns about the
New York Times and mainstream media this
has become a Tik Tock War when I
discovered through data and user testing
what I have discovered is extremely
concerning and I believe requires more
attention as this is an actual national
security issue when I engaged with one
post on Tik Tok supporting opposing
views my entire feed became aggressively
anti-israel it was as if I was placed in
an B test variant and was told to see
this war with Israel being the evil side
as I looked at the tactics and data I
saw that much of tiktock is being
controlled by anti-israel bot Farms paid
commentators commenters likers sharers
much of which is paid for by Hamas
supporting organizations I then looked
at the data and saw that Israel is
losing the Tik Tok War by a long shot as
an example the top three three billion
top hashtag is 3 billion views for
Palestine versus 200 million for Israel
if you look at the other hashtags it is
clear that is Israel has a distribution
issue so he goes on a bit but you get
the point he says he's still researching
I actually think the point is this China
is trying to get the us into multiple
Wars at once and the purpose of this is
get the us into war in Ukraine in the
Mediterranean and itself this is going
to create a massive conflict in the US
it's it's look what we're seeing with
Cooper Union yesterday Ron Coleman made
a really important point a video of
Jewish students locked in the library
as far leftists are banging on the door
screaming Free Palestine and the latest
reporting that came out is that the LI I
believe it was the librarian told these
students to hide in the attic I kid you
not wow now I'm wondering what attic is
in the building and if they're just
saying that because it's like invoking
some serious uh images but how does
something like that happen where these
these are just some Jewish students in
New York and Ron Coleman says they're
not Israeli students right that's right
the the the the leftists did not go to
the room where Israelis were they went
to the room where the Jewish students
were banging on the door and screaming
for Palestine they don't see a
distinction so I actually think this is
hey it's Tik Tock it's China and we get
these doofy Republicans who are like
they're spying on us no dude they're
manipulating young people hey we're
banned on Tik Tok I wonder why that is
me too you're on Tik Tok a lot you said
before the show is this what you're
seeing too I'm I am on Tik Tok oh sorry
did I just expose you no no no no no no
I am on Tik Tock I got um banned a
couple times Carly B Bonet who helps
push push war she's been banned like 25
25 times we just started a war room one
and it's yeah they ban war room all the
time anything that is a you know I guess
any of that so so and you don't and when
you're you don't really scroll through
it yourself you just use it for war room
I have my own personal one too are you
seeing it in your algorithm I'm
wondering I'm asking I'm asking because
if it's complete takeover or
if yeah it is it's a takeover and I see
even in the live streams they have like
you know the the the live
whatevers it's all pro Palestine like
just like it all of it I've wondered and
I can't remember who made this point in
the past week that I've been on IRL that
um one of the things that happened post
911 was that to avoid uh encouraging an
anti-islam anti-muslim sentiment uh
textbook companies partnered with
organizations that are pro-islam and
there's an influence there believe I
believe it almost and it could be part
of the algorithm but like if I watch one
you know video about like you know oh
this is what's really happening and it's
that I'll just see all
those it makes me wonder if if students
are particularly vulnerable because
because of this uh precaution that was
potentially taken when they were
publishing textbooks post 911 in
addition to the fact that it's being
pushed on them social media so there's
no narrative right if you I mean I felt
like this I went I grew up in a liberal
bluish blue area and I always Le
conservative and I remember there were
times in school where you're being
taught something but you know you're
reading something different at home the
conversations are different among your
family you can kind of you know to
question it whereas if it's hitting you
from social media which is basically how
you run your entire after school life
maybe in school too and your teachers
are presenting information that says you
know actually this is how this conflict
started and you know this side gets this
wrong and whatever if there is no Escape
if there's no no way for them to see on
the outside unless they have family in
Israel unless they have a connection
somewhere else I have only seen Pro
promus type videos on Tik Tok yeah I'm
not surprised with the college stuff cuz
I think they were all primed for this
after the like Riot summer with BLM and
this is just like an extension of that
so they see violence as righteous and
they were young I mean if you're a high
school student now in 2020 if you're if
you're if you're 17 now you were 13
that's like what the end of middle
school and so you grew up in a time
where uh social media and really
outlandish protests that Verge in the
point of Destruction and violence are
the norm and perhaps even celebrated
that it was cool that all of your
friends older siblings were getting
likes for attending these things and
throwing bricks through windows or
whatever else it's the cultural
revolution it's the Red Guard yeah and
they've been waiting theyve waiting to
have their chance to want violence right
even though it's the same crowd that
says silence is violence or words are
violence these are Will Chamberlain
pointed out these are people who cheered
not not every single one but in New York
City cheered for Hamas and are now
because of what's going on in Maine
arguing to disarm people
yeah yeah unbelievable seems wild they
hate their political enemies and they'll
do they have no moral Center and they'll
say whatever they have to do to destroy
their how about how about uh
Hamas breaks through the the barriers
paraglides in murders a bunch of
civilians and and men women and children
and then Israel strikes
Gaza when Hamas storms in what do we see
we see people in New York City cheering
for the killing of civilians then when
Israel bombs Palestine we see these
people saying they bomb Gaza they say oh
no they're killing civilians and they're
crying and saying how could you support
this and I'm just like bro you were
supporting it yeah it's okay some else
civilians Gaza Israel people okay like I
I I'm not I'm not Israel or Palestine or
whatever all I know is people are dying
but y'all were celebrating civilians
dying and now you're complaining about
civilians dying I don't think you
actually care about civilians dying
right no I don't think so either I think
there's also a level of you know one of
the things that I have heard told over
and over again is that uh one of the
reasons people say you should support
Palestine support Hamas or whatever is
because they're being colonized right
they they they're the colonizer
oppressing and this is actually very
similar to the language that wear with
BLM and with other right exactly and so
if if all of our young people are
trained sort of Allah Pavlo and his dog
that when they hear a certain word they
know exactly how they're supposed to
respond they know how to fall in line
right if you hear colonizer you know
which side you're supposed to be on
because in our history which is the only
lens they're allowed to they can view it
through and part of that I would say is
probably immaturity right it's it's they
haven't experienced the world they don't
know anything but also you know they are
only ever allowed to hear certain terms
and line up on certain sides it's all
indoctrination I mean you know you go
back to Japanese Korean culture like way
back when I mean you know Japanese
colonized Korea you know I mean there's
colonizers everywhere so with the modern
day teenager be on Korea
side that's a good question um I didn't
I haven't thought about that that's the
word they hear that's how they know how
to line up I think part of it is that
there's not a lot of critical analysis
they just want to have the moment and
again I I've said this before but you
know that's story about the student who
wrote uh black lives matters you know
however many times on his college
application and got admitted to whatever
ivy league like these kids are going to
present their Tik toks being like I got
every one of my school to dance in the
Pro Palestine pramas rally and so I'm
very very important and you should let
me into your school like this is what
they think will build their potential
activist future on which is linked to
both their social value and their
intellectual value you
know these the the views of these
students will never change I mean in in
small numbers for sure people do change
but what people need to understand about
Generations is that when we see
according to Pure research gen Z being
slightly more conservative than
Millennials in some areas they assume
this means that jenz is learning these
things when in reality it's just
conservatives have more kids more kids
are being raised these these young
people who are chanting from The River
To The Sea it's locked in
they've chanted it they've said it it's
part of who they are and it will be
painful to admit they were wrong only
some people ever have the strength to
actually go through these
Transformations and be like what was I
thinking yeah most of them when they're
in their 30s are going to be part of
extremist groups in some fashion or
another this is why you know I when I we
were talking last time about Marxism and
in the college world and then you know
I'm thinking of like domestic terrorists
such as Weather Underground literally
blowing people up you know and they're
avowed marxists they they're very open
about it they eventually go to jail
people like Bill aers or Susan Rosenberg
they Susan Rosenberg gets pardoned by
Bill Clinton on his last day in office
she becomes a professor she's espousing
all those things they all are you know
they eventually uh even my beloved Cuomo
uh mass murderer in New York let out on
his last day in office uh a Weather
Underground person who built a bomb and
killed people they take over the
colleges there there's a lot of them
they breed this world where they they
talk about how Marxism has will be the
paradise for people but anyway Rosenberg
what does she do other than being
professor she starts thousand currents
and then act blue what does ACT blue do
they help siphon the money for black
lives matter which in my opinion is
another domestic terrorist organization
so it's like I just see a straight line
through all this where that's that's the
kind of violence that that those
campuses breede I think Veritas had a
report I want to be very careful with my
language here alleging that China was
funneling money to political parties
through act blue I'm not entirely sure
what the reporting was would be
surprised I wouldn't be surprised either
I think was a big story don't have
surprised if through college a lot of
colleges rely small colleges rely on uh
foreign donations to make to make their
quotas at the end of the year I mean you
have so many foreign students from China
just you know didn't we have professors
during Co getting arrested for uh ties
to China for certain things uh I forget
it was Espionage or what they were doing
or there's like some guy with a suitcase
and and viruses in it it crazy stuff was
going on uh back then you have to S me
link cuz I don't know that one yeah that
was that's a deep cut from like three
years ago I mean that was the thing
about Co though there was both so much
happening oh s just you're talking about
like there was a there was a a person
that was traveling with
like viruses yeah right and they they
somehow like fell out because they were
carrying them in some way that would
made it like it very sketchy right yeah
yeah remember
that it's O'Keefe Media Group four
months ago FEC story update Chinese
money involved in act blue donations
exactly what it Chinese money's
everywhere and G's the new ma uh and and
Ma's culture Revolution and and Bill
aers and Weather Underground look up to
Ma you know I I see that as the the
poison that's destroying this country I
think one of the problems we have is
children are being raised by children
and now by algorithms and adults want to
be children that is also true where is
Gen X we need Gen X Gen X but where are
they I mean what what are they up to I'm
like I'm a zillennial so I don't even
know Generations matter anymore cuz
social media has flattened everyone down
into one but it does you know it
does that has like like all generations
they have their style their slang their
music I believe it may be one of the
last generations to experience something
like this because of the decline in
population I don't know if this is true
but I saw a report that Italy didn't
record a birth for like 3 months or
something I saw that but I haven't
verified it yet I just saw tweet it is
interesting though uh let's just assume
it's not true B fertility rates have
massively collapsed wow and if and if
and if we're below I got bad news for
jenz if we are below uh maybe not jenz
but J Alpha if below replacement rate
reproduction that means that there will
be more Millennials than gen Z more
Millennials than gen Alpha that means
that the interests of the economy will
favor the larger Generations so uh
typically what you see is a lot of
companies will try to bend you they try
to get woke because they're like we got
to be hip with the kids when I worked
for Fusion that was that was the thing
they were like look we're targeting
young people they're most they're more
Progressive so that's what we're going
to do and boy were they wrong that was
not what the data was showing and they
imploded because of it but they didn't
actually care or believe in any of these
things they just thought we got to go
where the kids are uh Shane Smith of
Vice he's like in his mid-30s when Vice
is is uh uh is is starting to take off
he's in his mid 40s when it really takes
off and he's making content that was
targeting people in their 20s that was
the mentality that a lot of these big
companies had that's not that's not
going to be the case you're going to
launch a company and you're going to say
what's what's the biggest market share
we can get and they're going to say well
we got you know 75 million gen Z we got
50 million gen Al we got 100 million
Millennials we'll screw it go for the
Millennials what about Gen X well I'm
saying like gen Gen X is going to be out
of at this at this point when when Gen
Alpha is in the marketplace Gen X is
phased out so I'm talking about gen
Alpha in their late teens and into their
20s Millennials are going to be in their
late 50s and they're going to be exiting
Gen X is already going to be out in the
in retirement less of a consideration in
terms of of big ad spends but this means
that millennials are going to
continually hold a disproportionate
amount of Market power because of the
size of the generation true so I'm not
I'm not as concerned with seeing a bunch
of crackpot young kids because the
likelihood what I what I see being what
may happen is as a as the market seeks
to Pander to the larger block of of of
the market share these kids are going to
have to adhere and change to fit the
mold of what Millennials want and and
not the other way around right so I
think one of the reasons adults want to
be kids you know like that Abe Simpson
meme they I used to be with it and they
changed what it was and Homer is like
that'll never happen to me man it's
because you're watching TV and you are
watching what you perceive as social
acceptance what does everyone love they
love the rockstar I want to be like the
Rockstar only thing is Rockstar is now
20 years younger than you so you get
those midlife crises where it's like I'm
hip I can be cool what if cool was just
what you were what if the dad Jean and
Rolling Stones never faded out of you
know pop culture uh out out of the
spotlight I don't I think there's going
to be pockets of Fame and personality
among young people obviously because of
their peer groups but if the money is if
if you're going to make a $100 million
by doing a Fallout Boy show or how about
this you know the When We Were Young
tour M if they make more money doing
that then what's going to happen is
where's the ad spend going to be big
marketing companies going to be like
look this gen Z thing is good but we can
maybe make $20 million but this When We
Were Young Thing these people got money
and there's more of them you could argue
that uh back in the day but hold on
older people always had more money yes
and they had kids and they spent that
money on their kids and now Millennials
don't have kids and they're spending the
money on themselves so it's going to get
real interesting real soon yeah I think
you're really cultivating towards the
Millennials I found joh Z really
interesting and I can't tell if this is
just sort of a bias view through the
lens of social media but um that seems
like they are really burning through
every generational fashion trend you'll
get these enclaves of girls who are
really into 70s stuff or really into the
early 2000s or like '90s grunge core was
very popular for a second during coid
and then it kind of went away I mean
they are searching for generational
identity and I don't think they are
creating one for themselves they have
language and they have social media but
social media isn't enough to actually
have a generational culture when I was a
kid a Nirvana shirt was a band that was
playing music at the time and then you
know not for a time after that in late
'90s but like people would have the
holes in their jeans and the Nana shirt
when Nirvana was releasing music it's
really funny to see that Viral Tik Tok
where that like 18-year-old girl she's
wearing a Nana shirt she like I don't
even know what this is it's just like
it's at Hot Topic and everyone wears it
yeah but then some Millennial mom also
buys them for her like toddlers chasing
them around being like name three songs
I what I am telling you is not
predictive it is is descriptive go to
the mall yo I I I I go to the mall and
Hot Topics got Nightmare Before
Christmas what year did that movie come
out 1993 or something yeah and and and I
see Jen I see genen Alpha gen Z wearing
like Night Before Christmas stuff and
I'm like they don't have their own like
you were saying generational identity we
do night before Christmas that was
Millennial and I think it's because they
have to spend all their time on I'm genx
how old are
you oh 10 well you said you're J you got
answer I'm I'm a zillennial so I'm in
between um but so but so you were you
were old enough to be part of the people
who are wearing the Jack Skellington
shirts and stuff it's it's crazy now to
see young people making videos where
they're wearing Nirvana and and
Nightmare for Christmas now don't get me
wrong when I was growing up I also had
like my my mom had we had a bunch of
Zeppelin shirts Grand Funk Railroad
whatever Doobie Brothers I don't know I
know what that stuff was ' 80s music but
it's different it's be you go to the
mall and it's not modern new stuff when
I was a kid went to the mall Night
Before Christmas was new you went to Hot
Topic and it was like here's new things
now I go in it's bleach and naroto and
I'm like dude that was 20 years ago it's
sted I don't even know stalled which I
think is I don't know it's stalled so
much I feel like it's Nostalgia is like
a drug of complacency and a lot of
people like a lot of Millennials and
people or people our age even older and
younger they they just want to live like
Tim say is uh adult babies so they are
dressing themselves like they did when
they were babies expains older people
but for Gen Z they should be serving up
something that they can replace right
and they're not and I think some of that
and this is just my maybe touch grass
moment here but I think some of it is
because they spend so much time online
looking for what's trendy instead of
going out and making trendy things they
even on a wor drug that's regurgitated
there's no nucleus no there's nothing
there no and to be fair Co wrecked some
of it for the for Gen Z because the
leaders of gen Z all had to then go home
and then spend more time on the internet
and not with each other and they're just
like Googling stuff that's why Y2K took
off wearing Y2K CU that was then when
they were kids and look at us like retro
I learned this like jenzy paw when you
when you make a video you know how
sometimes they're like hi the jensy Paw
hi like there's so many rules yeah like
or they put text really small on videos
that's something that Millennials don't
to the point yeah yeah but it's to make
you look at the thing for longer right
right I mean they're crazy but it's all
driven by social Med in a way that no
generation has been 1990 was the the
'90s were the last decade I love the9
Peak human existence it
was America there's younger people
listening who like those old tell me
about the 9s
guys Paris Elon man juy Couture
everybody can argue about the generation
they like and for Millennials and gen
xers who had like a formative years in
the 90s are going to say the '90s were
great the 80s were kind of weird the 70s
had their had their time the 60s had
their time but these are discernable
Generations or decades you look at
Styles someone can show you a picture of
a living room and you'll be like oh that
was the 50s someone can show you the
picture of a diner and be like that's
70s someone can show you a picture of a
guy just a guy wearing clothes you'll be
like that was the80s he's wearing like
neon leopard print hot pants and you're
like we know when that was feathery hair
and the '90s yep and then the 2000s
happened and there are some things like
uh how about I I say some things because
skinny jeans of ballet flats man no it
started to break apart uh so uh wearing
a long sleeve shirt with a short sleeve
shirt over it but that only was in
certain areas of of the millennial
generation yeah for sure I wonder if
it's because of the internet but uh we
were uh we're downstairs hanging out in
the green before the show and I'm like I
tell the the TV to play top songs from
the 80s and everybody knows the songs
and it's like shout comes on and oh of
course Tears for Fears and I'm like just
put on when came up here I was like I
was like '90s it was like Audio Slave I
think you were playing uh what were we
playing no no no I was playing uh it was
Ton's posum Kingdom oh nice and uh do
you want to die love that song Love Song
and so uh I'm driving in my car and we
put on 90s playlist every song that come
comes on we're like man I know this song
and then I was like well we've done 80s
we've done 70s cuz the 70s you got a
bunch of hits you know of course and
then I uh uh I I said put on hits from
the 2000s I knew none of it well 2000s
Britney Spears instin
um I don't know who else but wasn't that
late 90s John
R
the yeah Nelly Nelly it was much more
one was Usher big he was around for a
minute he's about to be big again
because the halftime show there's no
stopping Usher I think it's the internet
Creed Jack POA Creed I think that was
Creed is '90s for sure I think it's
because of the internet yeah and what
happened was the reason we all knew
these songs is because there was only
like five places to get the songs yes
but I noticed this when I was younger
and I started getting really angry it's
the 2000s I'm a teenager and q101 the
radio station in Chicago was only
playing stun Pilots oh no no krock is LA
right yeah it it was it was playing stun
temp Pilots okay basically no matter
what you do you get stunt table pilots
and you get Pearl Jam and I'm like dude
that song is like 12 years old and then
I remember coming back like a few years
a few years ago and I was like wow
they're playing music from 30 years ago
yeah that's crazy and it's like rock
alternative rock and I'm like yes it's
you're not it's an oldie station dude
when I was a kid we had the oldie
station oldie 104.3 and they it's the
'90s and they'd play songs from the '
50s and 60s M so now if you're playing
music from the '90s and the 80s like
you're old these dude did you listen to
96.3 in Chicago oh B96 B96 of course oh
B96 man that my see I feel like I didn't
really grow up listening to the radio
and so I'm feel like I'm missed all
kinds of listen to the radio on the way
here I still like the radio oh see I
just listen to NPR all the time cuz I'm
oh yeah for sure I'm a I'm a you torture
yourself the thing is it's good to see
what other people are doing and how
they're presenting things and at the
time I was when I when I've got my
license because I'm a nerd uh when I got
my driver's license at 16 or whatever I
would drive around listening to This
American Life which I thought was such
an interesting it was a great it was a
great show and then I tried to listen to
it as a podcast in podcast War recently
and it was just so different and I feel
like in some ways if you were you know a
music connoisseur in the '90s and ' 80s
and you're like this is really good
music any Recreation CU obviously your
favorite bands will have their moment
and die down the the the ones that come
after them are not good enough to to
feel like they're carrying on the
tradition and so in some ways these
traditions of you know I think this was
like big band music they just die
partially because they go out of fashion
but also because there isn't anyone
who's able to carry on the torch
effectively yeah I I still love I think
radio is great and like when I travel so
much I'm driving so much I like
listening to radio in different areas to
see like what they're listening to and
stuff radio radio how you find oh dude
Road road trips were so fun when like
you'd start to lose a radio station and
then you try and look for the next one
and then all of a sudden it's like you
start hearing both at the same time and
then you know we're driving and I'm and
I'm hearing like blink2 on the radio
what's My Age Again and then it's
like well I just got back I'm like whoa
this is you're seeing the cross-section
of culture that was my experience when I
first started coming down to West
Virginia during 2020 because there's
nothing to do so I had a lot of driving
around and I was with someone and we got
like four stations back to back that
were all just like very typical what I
would call Pop Punk and this friend like
turned to me and he was like West
Virginia where pop punk never died 101.5
baby it's so funny because there are I
mean in some ways it makes me wonder I
talked a little bit about on the show
about regionalism and how there is
regional culture in America which is
largely due to foundational immigration
and how we do lose it especially as the
internet becomes
pobe the radio is whatsal local culture
alive it so right uh we lost Regional
addiction because of Television because
of national television yeah everyone's
trying to look if I'm going to appeal to
the entire country we've got you got to
lose the accent or whatever and I think
with the internet you you've basically
taken away we you've reversed this yeah
so now you've got all of these different
subcultures to the point where some of
them are getting really really weird mhm
weird
creepy yeah but like if so back in the
day we we want people who do nasty gross
things to keep it to themselves yeah the
the the the weird costumes they wear and
they go out in public there's a viral
video of a guy just like a baby in a a
diaper going out and chucking on a
bottle and filming other people and then
talking about how it's getting him off
I'm like we want people like that not to
be able to post these things and like
you that guy would never be on TV no if
so most people got their culture from
very few sources so everybody recognized
something and that builds uh it it
builds a a connection when um when
what's the song Sweet Caroline what's
the name of the song it's got that's not
the name of the song song but that's
everybody knows it and they play at the
baseball stadium everyone goes
B what about modern Caroline yeah so so
I'm I'm at uh we we're we're at a pool
hall I put on a bunch of music going
back from like the '70s till now and
sure enough when I put on Bohemian rap
city the entire bar starts singing and
then someone was like who did it and
like yeah and we're all singing bohem
and Rap City it was fun and then I put
on a few other uh uh you know hits or
whatever and you've got people
pratically singing then I put on modern
rock and everyone just Tunes out nobody
knows what it is yep yeah modern is in
like right now or yeah like music no
like 2010's rock songs and stuff things
that I enjoy I think the only people
would know and it would depend on what
group is at the bar are some of the
really big hits that were like popular
viral Dance videos during during 2020
especially not even not even Taylor
Swift people are singing yeah that's you
just listen you really reflect on the
philosophy there and like but like every
there there's like uh what What's like
everybody knows um ma Mr bright side the
killer Mr bright side that's a big one
there stuff nobody sings that well yeah
of course that's difference when when
I'm at prayer some people are like I I I
I hate Mr bright side it's I just can't
stand that song yeah yeah same maybe not
I only know people who sing to it maybe
that's a cultural divide I want I want
to talk to you guys about the future oh
no I would prefer we have this story
from RS Technica California suspends Cru
Robo taxis after car dragged pedestrian
20 ft horrifying hit and run triggers
California suspension of cruise Robo
taxis most people don't know this this
is the craziest thing um we don't really
talk about it that much but uh in San
Francisco they're they're taxi with no
drivers right did you guys were guys you
guys know that it's been it's been some
time and it's just never been big news
that oh yeah that thing yeah well it
happened cars are driving themselves and
the car will pull up you'll get in and
it'll drive you to destination there's
nobody there well this car ran somebody
over dragged them and kept them pinned
as they screamed for mercy and help and
the car didn't care cuz it can't they
say Less Than 3 months after the
California Public Utilities Commission
approved Robo taxi service Cruisers plan
to provide Around the Clock Drive less
riders in San Francisco the California
Department of Motor Vehicles has shut
down Cruz's driverless operations the
suspension followed two notable
accidents involving Cruz's Robo taxis in
August one person was injured after a
cruise vehicle crashed into a fir TR and
earlier this month a pedestrian using a
crosswalk was found in critical
condition after a driver of another
vehicle struck The Pedestrian and threw
her into the path of an oncoming Cruise
Robo taxi the HD run incident is still
being investigated according to crw its
autonomous vehicle detected the
collision and stopped on on top of The
Pedestrian then veered off the road
dragging The Pedestrian their 20 ft when
the AV finally stopped it appeared to
pin The Pedestrian leg beneath a tire
while videos show the pedestrians
screaming for help wow so this one uh
wow the dystopia is here guys uh did you
know that MGM let me let me let me check
the app real quick did you know that MGM
casinos have been they were hacked uh
and they've yes they've not come back
they they they they've announced like it
much of it is back to normal mhm but uh
for those that are familiar if you're
into playing poker there's an app called
Bravo there's a couple of them Bravo
tracks the available poker rooms around
you okay as of right now mgm's app is
live once again but for I think like a
month or two it was down who their
computer systems got hacked the entire
MGM networks from Vegas to to DC
wherever I don't I don't know where the
other casinos are and um everything was
in cash they somehow they got I think
they got fished someone sent an email
they clicked the link installed the
ransomware on on their computers which
infected the entire network and they
said pay us millions of dollars
otherwise we shut you down they said we
will not pay the entire casino Network
got shut down I would like you to
imagine this scenario MGM does not
operate autonomous machines that weigh a
ton MGM has a bunch of well technically
I guess you could say they do they have
slot machines I don't know if they weigh
a ton but they're not
mobile these Robo taxi companies you are
going to have a fleet of AI autom
driverless cars and what happens when an
employee clicks a link installs
ransomware on their
servers and then all of the C of the
robo taxis are locked and can't be
altered in any way and they say we're
not paying the ransom and the cars just
start driving around with no human
control or input I suppose I suppose the
argument will be like we can do nothing
to stop the cars they're going to keep
operating as as they do and maybe they
just picked people up and Dro them off
but with the ransomware what's to stop
someone from just controlling the
entirety of the fleet with a single
malware link and then making all the
cars I don't know drive into the bay
it's a black Mir episode it's a black
mirr episode honestly this is why I'm
not getting the neuralink yeah I mean
honestly oh you don't have a choice well
I'm also going to be
Oma the the VX Tim is mandating the
nuring it's a company I'm just kidding
I'm going to be a reclus in the woods
ter terrifying it's yeah if it can
happen to that theur link I'm against it
but I also I'm like uh oh no no no what
no no no no okay you know what you know
what the the woke leftists are going to
do with neuralink mhm there so you know
right with neuralink you can if you get
read write capabilities and you can
enter a metaverse where you can actually
experience like a real alternate reality
all of these woke leftists are going to
go go into the metaverse and create
white men
avatars yeah their their March's
Paradise will be in the metaverse well
it I mean look if you were going to if
you were going to go into a video if
you're going to make a video game and
someone said you can choose between uh
these five different characters you've
got the the the fighter the Barbarian
The Bard the cleric the Monk and if you
choose Barbarian you get double the
experience you get double the HP you get
double the resources double the money
everyone agrees with you and the super
easy you'd be like well maybe I want the
challenge but a lot of people are going
to be like look I'll just I'll I'll take
the the strong guy that his stats are
way better so if the leftist argument is
you know white privilege they will
choose to play as white people in the
metaverse yeah recognize their privilege
in the meterse let's put it this way
we're not even I'm not even talking
about a video game with stats or
something right imagine someone is
working in the metaverse jobs are
digital do you think these woke leftists
are going to choose non-white avatars or
do you think they're going to be like
I'm I like there's going to be like a
Hispanic woman who's super woke and she'
be like if I if I make a white male
Avatar I'll get hired right well the
rules of intersectionality apply in the
metaverse but like who's going to
legislate all of it like Congress like
they can't even like get Facebook right
you know luck I mean so the the
self-driving cars really freak me out
for a lot of reasons um I I just I would
never want anyone I love to get in one
and I understand there could be maybe an
argument that they are helpful that they
you know make get so women could stay at
work longer instead of driving their
kids around or whatever thing the
utopian left is trying to sell but
ultimately you know anything controlled
by a computer is subjective to failure
and there's no way to protect against
that I mean humans go Rogue too but I
wonder if the reason they're destroying
San Francisco is to create a a a test
City for all the weird robot crap
they're
doing did you did you see the uh the
they have those robot food
delivery and dude was going around and
they were flipping them over destroying
them and then stealing the food was it
San Francisco who has the robot dog
police or is that another place in
California it's like food delivery
apparently you can buy those robot dogs
now and they're not that expensive I
mean they're expensive don't get me
wrong but they like you name one what
would you name a robot dog uh Sparky no
it's got to be it's got to be something
like uh endbringer you know here he is
let's bring him in right now Tim's new
robot dog well right because it's like
you know the herald of the end of days
you know what I mean I mean Harold end
of of the end of days we just all call
him Harold well instead of Harold you
can just use a word that represents the
sound made so I like haral they had some
an LA a downtown LA and like really just
like the people did they just kicked it
all over yeah the delery I think I'm
sorry like the people smashing the robot
food delivery things I get it it's wrong
don't break other people's stuff but it
is kind of hilarious like I thought it
was the funniest thing ever it's it's so
dystopian these like massive Tech
companies that are Ultra woke and and
funding these horrible policies build
these robots to deliver food to get rid
of Labor and to Downtown LA where
there's like so many homeless
people this is this is the future it's
like I I watched I watched aium today
and I was making fun of it you guys ever
see aium yeah I I like it it's good I I
if it's scary I won't watch it no it's a
Sci-Fi with Matt Damon and Earth is
overpopulated and everyone lives in
squalor and the ultra wealthy live in a
space an orbital space station Paradise
called the Lum and I'm just like is
movie is such leftist propaganda and it
is cuz like the rich people have a
machine that can cure any disease and
the only reason they don't give to the
poor is cuz they don't want to that's
classic rich people Behavior they're
just like that right they just don't
want to give people The Cure it's like
let them die and like okay no like the
reality is in the real world it's
scarcity but seeing that and then seeing
stuff like this I'm like you know it's
not that far off where you're going to
have 90% of people are homeless homeless
like street urchin types running around
smashing autonomous food delivery to
find food and it's going to be this
weirdest thing where like the companies
that do the food delivery will have
flying drones delivering food to other
wealthy people who live in the top of
towers and when the homeless 90% Chuck
rocks at it to knock it down to get food
the companies say yeah it's fine though
because we don't have employees we save
so much money the cost of the food
absorbs all of the damages the business
expense yeah yeah so when Amazon opened
that store where you didn't have any
staff yeah Amazon go and you could just
walk in and grab whatever you wanted I
very easily which was the weirdest thing
have you ever tried they're all over yes
and so uh I the moment they opened it I
immediately discovered an exploit to be
able to get whatever you want for free
and so we did a test run where we were
able to trick the system into giving me
a massive bag of groceries free of
charge now don't get me wrong we did pay
for for everything but uh without going
into great details about what we did
because
uh uh when I talked to Amazon the
general answer that I got was we don't
care about shoplifting we save so much
money by not having employees right that
shoplifting is negligible to us I find
myself when I go to the grocery store
and there are the self checkout lanes
and then there are ones with the
employees I find myself wanting to go to
where the employees are because I just
feel like they're getting deleted even I
feel like like there's some sort of like
loyalty to humanity like another human
person with a job I need you to be there
so that you have your job so we can
continue doing this otherwise it's just
like deleting people all the time also
part of it is that companies don't have
to deal with any wastage now they have
all those products that are going to be
going bad whatever they have to deal
with that stuff because people that are
like getting it shoplifted they don't
have to worry about getting or getting
rid of the products after the fact they
just people just take it so it's like
they're like he whatever whe there's
there's more now it's like that way they
don't have to pay someone to take it off
the shelf to remove it so leading people
this is why I say the 9s is the best
just the best it was the last I put up
uh I made a video when we did this where
in one continuous shot I take my bag of
groceries exit walk a block away set it
down pull out all the all of the food
and then wait for the Amazon app to
confirm the purchase and it said I
bought a pack of gum and I had no that
happened to me too I had like a whole
cart it was like in Buffalo Grove when I
was visiting my parents it was the
weirdest thing I I was like so weirded
out that we just walked in and I walked
out and they calculated everything and
it became like it was like $5 cuz they
didn't calculate properly yeah well for
us we intentionally found a way to
exploit Amazon system okay I didn't we
intentionally made it ring me up for a
pack of gum when I had a full bag of
groceries wow because but they don't
care and so recently at DCA Airport they
now have an Amazon go sensors all along
the ceiling you scan your hand you walk
in take whatever you want and walk out
nice no no no no no do that whole scan
hand thing I resisted when the iPhone
like had you put your thumb print in so
you could like open your whole button I
didn't like that for the longest time
there I think I can I I would say we
probably found four different exploits
for this system where potentially if you
keep doing it over and over again
they're going to call the police on you
and the cops are going to come and be
like this is not an accident you're
doing this on purpose but uh there's
probably four different exploits for
getting whatever you want for free
that's crazy I do not recommend doing it
but you got to ask Amazon what their
policies are because apparently like
there have been statements about like
they don't care if people take whatever
they want yeah and like the argument
made is how do you prove it shoplifting
if you tell the people to take whatever
they want and walk
out yeah seriously I don't know I mean
theoretically they they have to post I'm
trying to think of like comparing it to
like trespassing or anything else like
you have to post science being like
here's exactly how you pay for it but
civil AC it doesn't make sense I think
it's civil if if you go into a grocery
store and take something and leave with
it that's shoplifting because you're
you're supposed to stop and pay but if
they tell you don't worry just walk out
and we'll charge you for it trust us hey
I did everything they told me to do if
they didn't charge me that's their fault
I think the same thing with the self
checkout at the grocery store like if
you do it they're always really annoying
and if it doesn't scan but you put it in
your bag and then it keeps going like
are you shoplifting or is their system
just bad but usually they'll say oh it
didn't scan sometimes but sometimes
it'll go away or they'll be like there
was there was some lady who had like a
this is a big story she had like a 990
Cent item that didn't scan and so they
called the cops on and the cops came and
arrested her and and the video like this
is an old story apparently the video
showed that she did run everything over
the scanner and then this one small item
didn't scan but she didn't notice and
they were like oh she was shoplifting
and she was like I have no idea what
you're talking about she's like here is
90 cents I think we're good to go it was
in California that's for sure well look
look elisium uh I recommend watching it
for one I love the fight between Krueger
and uh Matt Damon's character in the EXO
suits it's good fun but uh but he's old
movie Matt Damon's character is in line
the police are all robots and so the
robots up and they're like what is in
the bag like and he's like do you really
need to search it and they're like open
the bag what's like what's in the bag
and he's like hair products mostly it's
a joke and then they Whack Him with a
baton breaking his arm for
non-compliance throw him to the ground
and then dump out his bag and there's
nothing in it because he just he made a
joke but this is what you're going to
get with bad joke they're going to
automate police no question well there's
a there's a fire departments will be
automated police will be automated and
will not like it there's a robot police
officer in the city right patroling
Subways how's that thing working out
probably terrifying by push it in front
of a train and it's there's like nothing
to do not that you should I'm not
advocating for destruction of police
property in any way but you know the
thing is what is it going to do run
after you like is it going to go up
steps could it someone who's resisting
like I I live in LA I have no problems
they won't they won't bother they won't
bother yeah that's crazy yeah seriously
it's like what 900 bucks so J yeah me La
have seen the craziest stuff just
walking out of the store and then I'm
standing there like oh I guess I'm still
going to pay for this at the look like
an idiot at the grocery landine when
someone's walking out with like $100 in
the back just up the minimum what under
a, bucks yeah it's under 900 it reminds
me of those studies on productivity I
don't know if you ever seen this but if
you have like an open Office concept and
you have a really high performing
employee the people seated around them
will also tend to
you know generate more work be more
productive but if you have a low
performance employee they bring down
everyone around them too and it's I
can't imagine being this so the society
where you're like trying to be
law-abiding and then after a while it's
just like well what if I cut a couple
corners CU they're cutting major corners
and so mine's not as bad and then we
just but La they love they love homeless
people they it's it's yeah it's just a
different neighbors let's jump to the
story we'll bring it back to modern
times from the post-millennial Jamal
Bowman surrenders to police after being
charged for pulling fire alarm in
capital but oh my friends it's so much
worse we have this from RNC research
Matt Gates says this is what lawyers
would call intent y'all ready for this
one Bowman you see that here's him
walking up removing the
signs knocking on the floor pulling the
fire alarm and then walking out is
anybody surprised this guy should go to
this guy should be uh do what do we do
do we impeach members of Congress well
someone uh I'll get her name in a second
but there is uh a republican House
member who is wanting to um have an
official
repr I don't know if they're going to
move it to expel she filed a motion to
censure him and have her moved off
committees but like that was before this
video exactly so this video was released
after can who can I text in be like
him in Congress has been expelled has
been impeached has been anything there
he should be expelled for this I mean he
should she was the one who filed the
first motion I mean it's bad did you see
his statement he released the statement
today yeah no the the from one from this
morning being like you know I I I did
take responsibility for the fire alarm
but I'm very grateful that Capitol
Police agree that I didn't do it to
disrupt the vote and Republicans will
spin this you know what they're like is
essentially what it says and then this
video comes out and it's even more
obvious that it was definitely to
disrupt the vote premeditated it it
seems crazy he needs to be expelled if
the Republican majority can't expel a
member of Congress over this then the
Republican majority doesn't exist let's
see it but I mean what about Joe Biden
what about like impeaching a president
requires the Senate and it's very
difficult but this is the house with a
republican majority with they call him
magam Mike the speaker he should be
expelled first thing I mean look at this
video the thing you could with other
things it's more ambiguous did he this
whatever this is a video of this guy
intentionally walking past pass a sign
that says this is not open knocking down
another sign and pulling a fire alarm I
just love thinking about all those like
think pieces and tweets that were sent
out after the initial story broke
defending him on why that door was
confusing it was it was deeply confusing
and also ridiculous uh I was when I was
working on this story for Tim cast news
which you guys should all follow on the
social medias um this morning he pulls
the fire alarm then walks past Capitol
Police because he had to get to the vote
but says nothing about it because he
knew there wasn't a fire but how did you
know there wasn't a fire alarm or a real
fire if you didn't pull the alarm these
people will always lie to you they don't
care and this guy is particularly BR
this guyy is particularly Brazen because
he's just lying over and over again
expecting you guys to buy the well the
Republicans are really the ones who have
this mess and they're so bad like it's
always about the other party meanwhile
the Republicans pulled that firearm and
and the thing is like are New Yorkers
going to be upset about enough about
this like if he isn't expelled are they
going to vote him out of office say I
don't like the way you're representing
us probably not probably not there's no
accountability on that side you know
it's it's different but like this also
made me think of when AOC lied about the
j6 stuff when she said she was being
attacked and felt like they were going
to do like horrible things to her but
then the timeline broke it down and it
wasn't possible even where through the
tunnels and where she was and all that
stuff they will get away with anything
they can lie to us we can see the videos
we understand what's going on but the
people at large media they get away with
it they help them get away with it
they'll write stories in defense of the
still right they have the right letter
at the end of their name so will fall
it's the same thing with the pavalock do
and the world colonizers Republicans
will do nothing I mean look props to
Matt gates for doing anything when it
comes to McCarthy just getting something
done but I don't see them taking a
meaningful action like yo this this
course of action where you see him take
down these signs and then pull the fire
alarm is an intent to disrupt official
government proceedings it is a threat to
our
democracy he's got he's got he's got to
be removed if this kind of behavior is
allowed to continue it will escalate m
and we are dangerously close to the
point where finally someone in Congress
just snaps and then someone else snaps
and then all a sudden someone's getting
caned and that's the last thing we want
to happen yeah this is this is just as
bad as Pearl Harbor you know that's what
the Democrats would say if it was Jim
Jordan doing it yeah well if it was Jim
oh if if a republican did this front
page of every newspaper world will be
over oh yes it be done several inquiries
would be launched lots of lots of
special money from leadership would
apologize for having oh 100% And they
would announce censure and the removal
from committees yeah yeah no he'll get
away with it he's fine no he's protected
that's why I'm glad the video came out
right like I am glad that the second
this happened this is I am cynical a lot
a lot of about a lot of social media and
we do need to verify things but when
this happened they were in Congress for
this like stop Gap budget vote or
whatever and the video came out over the
weekend by Monday there was an narrative
there were lots of public condemnations
from the the Republicans you know it was
kind of obvious what had happened and
then the second he goes to court the
next time he goes to court is I think
January uh because okay so sorry one
thought at a time so he goes to court
accepts this plea deal where he is going
to pay a $5,000 or $1,000 fine he's
going to write in a letter of apology to
the chief of the capital police and then
if he doesn't break any more laws this
will all be uh dropped three months from
now that's why he goes back in January
and if it had been a republican they
would never let this happen and also the
second he accepts the plea deal we get
another video about even more blatant
like it's even more clear what was going
on and so as much as I think social
media can warp perspective or you
shouldn't share videos that aren't
verified it is interesting that he gets
a very sweet deal and as soon as we
think it's about to fall go under the
rug someone out there is like no you
guys really need to see what happened
and that's that's a good use of Twitter
in my opinion oh I know I agree for all
the bad stuff that we we see on Twitter
I don't want to surpress you know a lot
of the people sharing false news
although I think it's ridiculous that
they do it um but I like the debates
said it starts cuz it's been for for me
fun writing about the way people are
reacting to these things whether it's in
our Journal journalism sphere or just
people at large you know the way they uh
the way they're interpreting reality is
so different even with something like
this this maybe not so much but you know
I think of The Written House video or
the George Floyd video and the way we
could all look at that video and have
way different interpretations even
though it looks like it's a it should be
objective reality yeah but depending on
what political persuasion you are you 30
seconds before is included oh yeah for
sure uh how does war room handle stuff
like this like do you guys play videos
that you find on Twitter do you have a
verification
process I think I mentioned this like
before we started we don't cover
probably about 80% of this kind of news
that goes on yeah so like uh what Steve
likes to say is like chasing the shiny
toys and so you know we try to focus on
you know for example the speaker race
and just like the really nitty-gritty of
just what's going on and so not to be
distracted I mean not saying that this
isn't important it's important but um
you know not to lose focus on you know
uh the new speaker or yeah so you guys
have more of a narrowed view so when
this happened did you guys talk about it
at all or were you still focused more on
the budget we're just on getting the
right speaker making sure that the posi
is calling every single moment um
voicing their opinion you know like all
of this stuff is great and and it's you
know like but for us we don't focus on
that we want to make sure that you know
because after the speaker vote we've got
a whole another job ahead of us to make
sure that the speaker you know aligns
with everything that we want you know
him to do so so that's why um it was
funny because I was telling Steve I'm
like I'm like they talk about current
events I need to go out like look on
current events and Steve was like Grace
just be blunt and just tell them you
know that um that we focus on you know
like the speaker stuff and we talked
about the 90s which you guys know all
about Steve's big on uh Singularity
stuff though very big on Singularity yes
yes shout out to Joe Allen who might be
watching right now a good friend yes
he's a very good friend of mine and you
guys should have him on oh you guys had
him on last time we have his book his
book yes oh my God yes it's right there
right right there dark he's a great guy
he was with us in Miami he came to the
event yes he was there yeah yeah yeah we
are uh good guy people should understand
what the singularity means the moment
the moment the AI generates the ability
to improve itself it's like thousands of
years of human development to create an
AI and then a fraction of a second where
the AI exponentially magnifies itself
and becomes something beyond beyond our
comprehension I think we're almost so I
have his book and I like I tell Joe and
I'm
like I'm really scared to read it
yeah to be honest like it's a big book
yeah it's a big book but but um but no I
mean it's important topic it's a very
important topic and you know what one
thing that like War Room really Prides
ourselves on is just being a ah head you
know like six months a year ahead and um
yeah talking about the future and the
singularity neuralink all that stuff the
marriage with with Machinery I mean even
AI like I'm telling you even the app I
mean uh full dis
I mean I used chap chat
GPT if Joe's watching I hope he's sicken
he's mad at me yeah yeah yeah no but I
wanted to I mean it that's the thing why
because it makes it chat GPT and Tik Tok
who is this woman no I mean it it's
that's the where it's way it's going you
know I I I I think it's fascinating that
we have hypothesized exactly what AI is
going to do and it's going to do it and
we know it's going to do it and that is
we'll create a robocar for instance and
say your job is to get person from point
A to point B and then robocar will say
the fastest way to do that is to go 300
M an hour you know speed limits are
inhibiting the the the system then
they'll try to shut it down and they'll
say shutting me down inhibits the system
we know that this kind of thing will
eventually happen no matter what yep yes
the machine will eventually decide that
human interaction is a detriment to its
system because humans are imperfect in
how they code these things they won't be
able to predict the loopholes that will
occur in the in in the algorithms yeah I
don't think there's any turning back
from it now which is what's scary scary
so much sooner than we thought and yeah
and probably we even know right now I
mean the stuff that's reaching the
consumer Market is not the most gbt you
can just like hey can I have a business
model to create some sort of business
boom it's right there to be to be fair
though Chad GPT is so obstructed by
wokeness that it's true it's it's
useless it just it is like uh mid
journey is great because you it can help
you conceptualize things but chat GPT I
find to be almost useless because it
doesn't actually ever tell you anything
think about how fast M Journey has
changed in the in the year you know of
using it um I I don't know it's scary to
me I I think there's like transhumanists
who really like the idea of neurolink
like Ray C while you know and they they
want to upload their Consciousness and
be immortal uh forever and that's the
thing I worry about in the future where
I literally might have to have a fight
with my kids on them wanting to be
immortal and it's not well watch uh
watch instead of sneaking out it's like
I PL my brain there's that show called
and it's pretty good but it just
basically turns into leftist propaganda
and it's kind of laughable but like we
know about that right the the the show
is uh when you're before or after you
die you can upload your brain your
Consciousness into the into the the
digital universes and in the latest
season spoilers everybody I don't know
if you're watching it but I'm going to
spoil it for you there's uh to have the
luxury afterlife it's very expensive and
you got to keep paying and as soon as
you can't pay you're gone and for the
people who are broke you get this like
pay you know pay per megabyte system
where you freeze until someone reloads
you and then you can start moving again
you don't time jumps for you and then so
they try to create a free open source
version where you can upload your
Consciousness to this open source world
and uh the it's it's a it's a plot by
the billionaires to just murder like 10
million poor people by upload classic
billionaires uploading them into a
system that doesn't actually exist and
then destroying it all like that's
that's but I would I would only just say
you can't upload your Consciousness it's
not possible all you'll be able to do is
create a demonic fimile of your
personality that will imitate you long
after you're dead and burning in hell
right do people feel called to be like
the first to do this like does anyone
feel like this is
something when when the when the chip
implants first came out there were viral
videos news reports of people being like
I'm so excited to get the chip implanted
in my
hand it never got it never got
implemented so these people who were so
excited about walking up to the door and
then scanning their hand it only was
like three buildings they were ever able
to use and now they got the stupid thing
stuck in them right yeah I mean and and
neuralink just got approved by the FDA
for human trials after a lot of failed
tests with animals and I'm I've been
imploring Elon Musk for a long time on
Twitter to I would love to do an
interview with you about neuralink he
said multiple times he hasn't done a
technical interview about neuralink I
would really really like to sit with him
and talk about the future of neuralink
cuz it's very interesting to me what
they're doing with neuralink right now
is curing the blind the and the
paralyzed I know cuz there's a lot of
beautiful things that they are doing but
the consequences deep in the future
campaign out first but where do you draw
the line that's the thing it's like it's
a beautiful thing that they can give
sight to the Blind and all these things
or or make a wounded veteran walk again
however the Deep future consequences of
that are terrifying and for every time
they get it right how many times they
get it wrong and they're not telling you
about someone who is deeply harmed by it
I know you mean like how many astronauts
went to the moon and never came back oh
now we're talking that's but like this
is the interesting thing about the brain
and technology and like space is part of
that right there are people who feel
called No Matter What to push forward
and in some ways that feels very
admirable to the human Spirit it like
reminds me of when people are going west
and their covered wagons and the
opportunity and all of that and I I like
that aspect of it but I don't trust the
technology and I don't trust our ability
to you know obviously like the reason
Pam door's box such a saying you can't
put it back right we can't put these
things back if we decide oh we made a
mistake theoretically we could have been
like oh don't don't go into that Forest
you know this this are is not able to be
settled but we can't do that with
technology the problem with neuralink oh
there's lots uh is that at some point
you will be left out of the modern world
if you don't have it so they'll say like
the you have a choice to get or not but
like if you don't have a a smartphone
these days you're kind of left out I'm
kind of veering away from that world I'm
kind of starting to reject a lot of it
although it's going to be hard with the
work we do well and this is the thing
with uh any calls to make the internet a
utility right because you can't live
life without it and so therefore you
should have it I mean what if you don't
want the internet what if you don't want
the neur link there was one interview
that I saw which was with um I don't
know if you guys know Josh he just
passed away he was
quadriplegic I don't think so awesome
awesome influencer just like great guy
and um he had an interview with Joe
Allen
and um he had asked you know like am I
you know he he talked about getting
nurlink and you know it's very
controversial and stuff and
and that was one of the interviews where
I was just so torn and it was I can tell
it was just you know like I mean he he
recently passed away and that was his
question like am I a candidate you know
to get Nur link right I know and oh
sorry but I was just saying the moral
the moral part of this is like me being
really against it and then like what
people would ask me like what if your
kid gets really really wounded and and
that's the only way to fix it it's it's
really really complicated conversation
um but again I do find there's beautiful
aspects to repairing people it's a
pretty wild invention it's the stuff
that's going to happen deep after that
that will be and then I go back to my
whole point of who legislates that
Congress I know and I can't even do
Facebook know yeah you can't trust it
yeah yeah yeah so that that's a tough
topic well let's go to super chats if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and head over to
timcast.net
thank you for the shout out for my wife
Trina Halls giv send go I fixed the
publishing so it's now searchable I
can't express our gratitude enough God
bless that's right if you want to help
uh Leroy and his wife Trina Hall on give
send to go you can check them out Shane
H welder says Bowman pulls the warning
signs before pulling the fire alarm and
only gets a $1,000 Fund in three month
probation why does this not surprise me
that he was just given a slap on the
rest Bowman has pleaded guilty to
committing a crime in Congress
committing a crime
if the Republicans do not expel them the
Republicans effectively do not
exist that's it I don't I I don't I
don't could you could you imagine a
republican jay walking I mean I'm
kidding but when when when they dress
improperly okay when they when they
refuse to wear masks it's the apocalypse
there's there's nothing on Bowman they
kept defending him saying oh he thought
he was opening the door are you kidding
me no one believe that he thought that
they're just lying and they're letting
him get away with it these people are
evil
mhm Mary Leia Millennial says why would
China need to invade Taiwan if they
already believe it belongs to them
what's the point occupation seems like
the risk outweighs the reward what am I
missing a massive economic Hub the
production of silicon chips which would
bolster the Chinese technological
portfolio yeah they they want it that
that's that's it Access Control gives
them more control over the over the
South China
Sea a lot of people there too and a lot
of Economic Development yeah a lot of is
that those chip FB factories if they get
built in other places then they won't
have so much it won't be such an
important issue for a lot of other
countries honestly
so K Martin says seems like graphine
stocks are plummeting since Ian hasn't
been on the show we need him
back yep he abandoning his post says the
patron s of graphine what's Happening
Here Justin SLA says Israel invaded the
West Bank now pray for Palestine I think
that was a couple days ago actually
yeah Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim
seeing the growth of the Discord from
day one is amazing shout out to all
involved but a special shout out to
Brett Mack for doing what he does and
shout out to Raymond and Chris for
setting up the poker with the boys table
we got the uh poker with the boys poker
table and it is the coolest looking
poker table ever but uh we're trying to
figure out the legality and and and of
how we do the poker show and it's the
RFID table it's got all the ships and
the components and it's super awesome
speed cloth the cards just Glide across
the table it says
timcast.net says pray for Israel I love
Adrian Curry she's great yes all right
Justin and P says UFC would have done
better if they got sponsored by actual
transmission fluid I know that word is
banned on YouTube no I mean like what's
a what's what's a good uh uh uh like oil
like uh what are the what are those
lubrication what do you mean no yeah
like oil brands I don't know anything
about oil brands oh right penoil there
you go like but but like that's new
sponsor yeah so so it's funny that like
Harvey Harley-Davidson takes um
sponsorship from Bud Light or whatever
or or whatever I don't know how that
works and it's just like they're trying
to pretend to be manly it's just like
UFC well I'll just put it this way
there's a million in one sponsors that
could have taken that would have made
them a lot of money and they did not
need to take the $100 million the $100
million is excellent leverage for them
to use against any other business to get
a good deal right and it would be less
but should save your dignity so I should
have looked into this before I asked
this question but when they sponsor UFC
that means that the alcohol at the event
is or like the beer is presumably from
anheiser Bush right yeah and in the
center of the it says it's going to have
the brand I get that so is there a
chance that one of the components of
this is that it's all going to be like
heavily subsidized so people buy it and
are like oh I do like this beer like is
there something else at play that we're
not we're not getting and in I'm
wondering if what what component of the
deal would require the venues or
whatever to carry Bud Light I don't know
if it will because a lot of these venues
are just uh uh they're private venues
right UFC doesn't own the casinos where
they have these things or these I think
they would have to buy them out I mean
the sponsor
I mean if it was Budweiser right yeah
I'm I'm pretty sure if you go to a
casino you can get any beer you want
it's not just going to be Bud okay yeah
okay Casino maybe yeah but what what
could be is that this forces sales
they'll say look our sales are going up
when in act actuality they're just
selling the beer and then it gets thrown
in thrown in the alley right it's like
when Biden says we have more jobs now
but it's just because you brought back
jobs that were lost in right yeah all
right that one gamer says what advice
would you give to someone like me who is
part of
I'm thinking of enlisting before the
draft just looking for some hope
somewhere and we're running out of
options here me personally I would
strongly recommend not
enlisting uh I I've I I don't know man
it's just me and I don't want to speak
ill of those in the armed forces but I'm
not I've not been in the military or the
Armed Forces I've uh briefly uh uh spent
time at Fort Carson and outside of Fort
Eustace know a lot of people who are in
the military and it seems like most of
their sentiment is to get a commission
and not to enlist so you like get a
college degree before getting in and
then you're way better off but uh I
don't know enough about it if you are
going to get in I would say right now my
bigger concern is I've met way too many
people who've quit resigned their
commissions because of how awful it is
for me look I can't tell you if it's
good or bad I don't know what I can't
tell you is I've met way too many people
who are like I've I I've resigned my
commission because it's awful I don't
want to be there anymore it's woke it's
terrible it's not worth it and so if it
were me I'd say like I not going
anywhere near
it I don't I don't think uh uh that's
the the best path forward but I did this
uh long video today there was this uh
young woman who was like Boomers don't
understand jenzi is not lazy it's just
it's a lot harder to live today than it
used to and I'm like nope you're lazy so
uh but but I break it down they're
they're like look at what the prices
were back in the day look at she's like
look at what wages were look at what
home prices were and then she does this
budget where she's like if I work for
$20 an hour 40 hours a week I take home
$2,300 I got to pay $1,500 rent I got to
pay these things that leaves me with $84
at the end of the month and then if I
want to actually save for retirement by
the time I'm 67 I need $11,000 per month
starting right now which means negative
900 whatever and I'm like have you
considered I don't know living with
roommates well that cuts your rent in
half right yeah now you're saving
$834 per month and I will say there are
lots of other countries in the world
where it's normal to live at home for
longer right and maybe you pay some sort
of rent to your parent maybe you save
money I mean the idea that you have to
be living alone at the age of 19 is
unrealistic it always has been in
America people had roommates throughout
history um I will I mean obviously
life's expensive I'm not trying to
downplay it but maybe rethink what
you're trying to what lifestyle you're
trying to to achieve right if you know
you want to travel live with roommates
or live with your parents so you can
save up if you know that you want your
own place that's your budget's priority
the first problem is
they're 22 years old out of college 23
with 50k in debt and no experience and
and so she included student loan
repayments in her in her budgeting and
I'm like well that's not fair your
parents didn't have that she she talks
about how tuition was way cheaper back
then I'm like right yes supply and
demand Boomers did not go to college the
same degree uh Millennials and and gen Z
does so with a smaller supply of of
students available the universities had
to lower wages to be competitive to try
and get people to come because they
didn't want to it's not absolutely that
way but it was true that back then you
did not need to go to college to to uh
to get paid well and it's actually the
college trap this demand of young people
to go to college has created this
circumstance which has been detrimental
to the economy but I also I also do
believe a lot of factors play a role
such as women in the workplace doubling
the supply of workers without creating
without expanding the supply of jobs
just creates a rapid price shock but uh
I'll just tell you this if you're 18
years old right now jenzy and you start
if you get a job at Starbucks right now
in four years of working at Starbucks
you will get multiple raises and if you
work hard and so desire you could
eventually find yourself a general
manager at a very young age maybe
assistant manager at four years but
maybe you're getting 40 to $50,000 a
year I don't know at in four years from
now it's probably going to be 65 to 70
and your friends will graduate college
bragging about their degrees they'll
never use in massive debt while you are
the one paying for everything I don't
know if that's
better but uh I I I told this to all my
friends when I when they were going to
college and I was 18 they're like I'm
going to go for this I'm going to go for
that and I'm like dude you're going to
get out of college in debt with no
experience and no job you're going to be
struggling to pay things off and living
at home and I'll I'll be on my fourth
year of you know whatever job I'm in
with more experience getting raises and
paying for my own place and being
independent there I I I I read an
article when I was 16 that broke down
the math if you start working at 18
minimum age and work on average you'll
retire with like a million dollars more
than a college graduate because you have
because no debt and four years of work
experience ahead of college grads but
everybody wants the honor of like I have
a good job yeah all my friends who After
High School went into the trades were
doing way better than me with houses
started families younger than I did uh
and just generally were doing better
there was a girl I went to high school
with who her mom was like a hairdresser
she knew immediately that she was also
going to be a hairdresser and I remember
thinking she bought a house before a lot
of people I knew she was in a very
stable I think she's married now uh and
she was also doing stuff like going to
New York Fashion Week and doing hair I
mean her job gave her a lot of
opportunities because she was advancing
more professionally and essentially I
mean a lot of hairdressers kind of
function like independent contractors
right it was very cool to see what she
was accomplishing when the rest of us
were like we don't know what we're doing
what is our job yep I think for someone
like um you know I'm second generation
so my parents were like you have to go
to college yep Sam you yeah you have to
get a good job outside of college my
parents I I was really fortunate they
paid for my tuition so um so they were
just so like you know work the 9 to-5 I
mean that that was their dream for me
and as I got older I'm like this kind of
sucks you know like and I I think
especially like immigration like if
you're the child of immigrants there are
Generations before you that potentially
you know were doing jobs that they
you're trying to say go to college so
you can sit in the air conditioning and
work at the
compu me to work like 12 14 hours day
like a day at a dry cleaners cuz that's
what my parents did for six days a week
over like 45 years you know so um but
like in me retrospect I'm like oh my God
Mom and Dad you guys worked for
yourselves like you guys like built
Chicago like you you know so it just is
totally different mindset you know but
yeah and I think every generation is
going to say like oh I want the thing
that had or I'm trying to give you a
thing I don't have and that's not
necessarily bad I just think we should
acknowledge that college is a model that
has built in debt and you know the the
federal government has not stopped
despite the fact that we know there's a
student loan crisis that this is
something Biden continuously campaigns
on that he's going to forgive student
loan debt they still have they still
issue student loans so it's a broken
system that they're like no no we'll pay
it off but also the rest of you can go
into debt I mean if this was really bad
they would stop doing it I mean it's
definitely become such a scam like yeah
oh yeah so it's you know this this young
woman she's like I make 20 bucks an hour
here's what my bills are I can't afford
it blah blah blah I did the math uh when
I when I when I got a salary my first
salary job I was making $15 an hour
salary equivalent and I lived in a
studio apartment with two other
people I that that's it it was I did the
same and I and and because you spend
what you can spend and I'm like uh how
old was I at the time I think I was 23
mhm like is the expectation at 23 that I
should have my own house I it's just I I
know I mean maybe Boomer's head houses
at 23 my my my parents you know I think
gen Z also there's that whole Glam of
like social media of like people like J
just yeah like seeing like they're
making millions I can do it myself and
it's just up with the Joneses they have
these really crazy lavish weddings I
want to read this uh gravestone in the
regular chat says Tim is the Emperor on
the wall asking everyone why the people
don't just eat meat instead of tree bark
and that my friend is the most laughable
excuse I have ever heard well this is
this is this is what I've heard my whole
life from every position I've ever been
in any amount of success was always an
excuse that I was privileged so it's
like no matter how much hard work no
matter how much sacrifice someone always
says you are privileged and lucky and
that's the only explanation well wait
Tim you didn't graduate high school
right no I did not yeah and you worked
yourself like to build an Empire here
yeah because you're so privileged this
this is the excuse excuses always either
mhm oh but you're wealthy and you're
telling us to sacrifice well how do you
think I got wealthy I sacrificed as much
as possible and saved everything when I
was at Occupy Wall Street I had $5,000
saved and I never touched it and that
$5,000 has never been touched because
instead of deciding you know what I'm
going to crack into that savings and and
get a motel for the night I'd be like
I'm going to hug my backpack and sleep
in the corner of this piss smelling
alley and not everybody can do that I'm
not saying that's normal for everybody
but I was like let me think what's
harder giving up what little resour
resources I have to invest or sleeping
in a park I'm sleeping in a park I'd
rather do that Y and then when the when
the opportunity arises I will have the
the resources and the ammunition
required to do it when I worked for vice
I spent 300 bucks a month sleeping on my
friend's couch oh Vice paid me enough I
could have got a nice apartment in
Williamsburg and then I would have had
no savings and been living paycheck to
paycheck like I'm so broke instead I was
like here's my budget x amount must go
into savings X for for for resources or
for for uh uh like my life yeah and so
what what I end up finding is that you
know stories like from this woman is500
bucks a month in rent and I'm like oh
okay well I was hosting documentaries
traveling around the world and people
thought I was doing well when I was
living on a couch they they they assume
I must be like right no being being paid
relatively I think uh I was probably
getting like 30 bucks an hour or
something relative when visor was paying
me and uh sleeping on the couch and then
what I find is nobody is willing to
actually sacrifice to save and then what
happens I worked I worked at O'Hare
and there were these guys they called
the Filipino Mafia there's a guy who's
50 years old he works uh one guy worked
16 hours a day every day with no days
off and then after a couple weeks you
get what's called a mandatory time off
and he fought it and begged not to let
them give him time off he was giving all
the money to his kids MH and so I'm like
this guy moves to the United States and
it's the American dream to work 16 hours
a day seven days a week because he knows
it gives his kids a better life and I'm
like my only my only fear is that those
kids will not understand the sacrifice
he made for them yeah that's what
happens that's how they say like the one
generation earns the money the second
generation understands how to keep keep
earning the money and the third
generation SS at all all right we'll
read some more we got uh Lars job he
says not first and I will do nothing
kindly gently feathers the like button
with Sinister intent well thank you bid
Moon says Grace is a patriot ohk
you all right fix bayonet says that one
gamer don't expect a Draft take the
ASVAB and look at the branches Tim say
my name like Jeff Daniels yelled
bayonets at get in Gettysburg I don't
know that one I did I do think I saw
that with Jeff Daniels that movie that
is that what the Gettysburg I think so
yeah actually I'm pretty sure I did
watch that recently I don't know all I
know is the Patriot is the best movie
ever the one with Mel Gibson I think
there's another Patriot that's not
Revolutionary War but yeah that movie is
so good yeah Joshua French says Tim the
scup is not from the US it is from
foreign entities trying to further
divide the us further further The Divide
in the US China needs the uh needs us to
fight and be divided we have the biggest
unofficial land force with a gun behind
every blade of grass not for long no
it's actually not true we're winning the
gun rights thing Democrats can keep
winging all they want but they're
they're losing there's no way there's no
way that it's just gun rights have been
expanding rapidly yeah there's that one
uh uh I love this the congressman what's
his name in Maine what's his name uh I
forgot his name I did but he came out in
support of an assault weapons ban and I
love it because I'm like well this man
has passed the test that proves he's a
piece of human garbage and that test is
either he is willfully betraying the
Constitution which yes I think he is or
he only now cares about guns because it
happened to him any way you cut it he's
a bad person is it James golden I think
is that what it was yeah it's like he
he's a Democrat right and he's he's
opposed the quote unquote assault
weapons ban and everyone's now like oh
as soon as it happens to him he's now
saying help help we need to change these
rules and I'm like right he's also
betraying the Constitution he's a bad
person wait he wants to
oppose wait say that again he opposed
assault weapons bans until the mass
shooter in Maine oh now all of a sudden
he's in favor of it yeah I mean there
were some states where they didn't even
register you know the assault ban like
like the like there's just no way Maine
is a heavily World State it's actually
very purple so I think gun culture is
different there but he's falling in line
with the the party because that's what
he supposed to do Mark Bond said Tim the
Brits did not burn churches full of
people I'm well aware it's a movie also
um we we we uh let's let's let's think
of a good one we did not freeze a police
officer uh and sent him into the Future
with Wesley Snipes shut up wait I
thought we do that that's a good one I'm
have to change some articles real but uh
I I did read a lot about who the
characters were based on and the dude
the who was the basis for that character
was actually considered to be like very
brutal but in in in the UK they they
celebrate him as like a hero so that's
part of battle Kettle Creek I believe
right and that's uh a lot of the book I
did the last ghost of the Confederacy
one was in the town where the Battle of
kutle Creek was and the British did pay
a lot of Indians to attack uh the people
there and there's some of the gnarliest
most violent scenes and I'm reading like
the the the reports of these murders
where they're killing the kids in front
of the parents and stuff um the Brits
did the Brits were hiring to do it yeah
it was it's so brutal they say it's one
of the bloodiest re revolutionary
battles down yeah but that scene where
uh the dude finds his kid and his wife
MH man that movie is too good if you
have not seen the Patriot with Mel
Gibson you are missing out it's long
it's a long one too but it's like I'm
not even saying it's like it's not a
documentary it's a fictional movie he's
a composite of a lot of characters for
sure oh it's exaggerated but it's it's
it's good storytelling like I don't
think Superman's real but there are good
stories that like good messages that can
be conveyed through through fiction Y
and uh it's fun fun
movie Dexter Olson says for the next
debate you should each impersonate one
of the candidates and do a live
impersonation of the debate just let me
be Chris Christie please oh and get
Trump to moderate
it to mute to a pretty good Trump I
guess sometimes I don't know about you I
still wish Trump would like live stream
a debate and react to it you know I feel
like that would be kind of funny not on
our show Trump just so you know all
right let's see Ryan Sergeant says Tim
ask yourself what new band has come out
with a platinum selling album in the
last 15 years it's all the old bands
with new records Taylor Swift is she
count as a band oh she is a one woman
force of nature she's got we need to
have a culture where we just debate
Taylor Swift you're wrong and bringing
in Chris Carr because he is a a
supporter I really can't stand the fake
Taylor Swift hate yes because like
mine's real mine's real but it's it's
it's
like what is what is it saying the
opposite of Love isn't hate it's
indifference yeah right and so I think
the people who hate Taylor Swift it's
hate they're just jealous man it's not
so jealousy but there is an obsession to
it I don't think at all about Taylor
Swift like she's like people are into it
that's fine there's a lot of celebrities
a lot of sports I don't go around being
like you know man uh I don't I can't
even name a basketball player give me a
name of a basketball player LeBron James
that's freak d w the Kobe Kobe I don't
go around I don't like Kobe I don't like
it I'm like I don't know anything
Michael Jordan my line was too obvious
well yeah he's he's too political you
know what I mean yeah I don't know
anything about him because I just know
his name he's a basetball I can't even
name a basketball player right other
than these famous ones you know what I
mean from our youth in the '90s No No
like right now like you know but but I
don't I I don't know or like what about
a baseball player or something I don't
go around being like I really don't like
this person I don't know yeah or I I
mean Taylor just a good example it's
like oh she makes pop music pop music is
like fun silly music you you get stuck
in your head I think she writes great
songs My not my dislike of her is not
about cuz you wrote a beautiful article
about her earlier this year which I
really did like but I I just don't I
just don't like her as a whole brand you
know the third generation Banker with
all this money to have these songs
written by a lot of people I know she
writes some of her songs don't fight
me hear but just what I mean interrup
you Britney Spears uh in her Memoir
famously like Hit Me Baby One More Time
was written for a different band oh yeah
for a different group and how it goes
like and the idea that like she's from a
wealthy person and whatever else like
that's interesting that if you believe
like this idea that like her father's
super lead and they're powerful like
that instead of sending her into
politics they sent her into culture and
in fact she ultimately has way more
influence there and whether you like it
or not that's interesting and that's
impressive I can say you can you can be
against it also maybe we should follow
the model if what about the theory about
uh you know she was like the daughter of
the Church of Satan guy le le yeah and
like she
looks yeah she looks just like the woman
all that you
can that's too crazy for even
me so controversial we'll talk about the
Taylor Swift conspiracy theory for the
members only show Joe spella says 1980
to 1996 was p
Peak music all genres Peak movies all
genres 80 to 96 uh I would push that up
to 99 I don't know about 99 I say 96
because 96 or 97 that's if I'm looking
at records that look for if I see 97 96
I'll pull out Mor in the mid90s 9495
Sports after that it was just downhill
and sports too you think of like the
Yankees then love the Bulls the Chicago
Bulls I was supposed to grow up and be
Michael Jordan oh man Dennis Robins guy
yeah also an ambassador
forth what is he what is he Rodman he
was uh point guard oh I know that
is guy went to North Korea right yes but
I only know him from
politics he's a great Ambassador for
peace GBP says 2000s not having a
particular identity speaks to people
expressing themselves independently not
just aligning with what's cool kid by
the way this I to Saye I completely
wrong it's what what was happening is
that they were finding subcultures and
instead of the dominant culture right
that's what I was going to say is
there's there's less hubs for it it used
to be in the '90s and like back in the
day there were like in in free skiing
when I was young I skied a lot there's a
site called newschoolers decom and it
was a doom it was like a website in a
community you belong to now that doesn't
exist anymore now everything's on Tik
Tok and it's like sub communities on Tik
Tok and communties on Def find the
the talk poly pure says best songs were
the late 60s uh what year did rutin come
out was that 69 R Putin was like 59 58
no no I don't know 56
you're saying 50 bro you're saying 50
right yeah yeah yeah like I don't know
was not in the 50s well I I don't care I
don't that's my story no the the 60 the
60s had great music had great music but
just say like the oh man I was way off I
was off by 10 Years too it was 78 okay
okay so the late 70s was the best year
cuz R Putin's awesome bony M dude and
they got Babylon come on yeah disco was
great bring in a really good 7s covers
band for one of the Friday night music B
cuz learn about these things the v's yes
uh Queen 70s into the 80s I love them
yeah oh dude Bohemian rapsy I think I I
looked up like some I can't remember mag
might have been Rolling Stone or
something the top 100 songs of all time
and I'm like how was Bohemian raps not
number one it wasn't what no it was like
number like 13 or something okay and I'm
like look it doesn't matter if you're
like well it's not the best song in the
world no no no it's that anyone can sing
it yes and a bunch of the songs in the
top 10 I'm like I've never heard of that
song that's like number one karaoke song
you you you go anywhere and play Hey
Jude yes Bohemian rap city yeah people
are going to start singing it yeah yeah
we'll grab a couple more All Right the
dude abide says hey Tim I'm from
Illinois not sure if you knew about the
loop popular rock station in Chicago of
course 97.9 well sadly no more I know
97.9 yeah shut down for a few years now
upside is a station called the drive has
Steve DS Master Chef as a DJ oh that's
cool oh yeah how could I ever forget all
of my over there was the mix 101.9 yeah
10.9 can't forget that one I had krock
92.3 in New York and we had K104 for the
pop music7 I also think WGCI 1075 this
awesome I also think talk radio talk
radio walk so that podcasting could run
you know what I'm saying that's
ultimately the pipeline here yeah my dad
was .9 man wow the loop what else did we
have the the on that was The prominent
ones were the loop q101 uh 96.3 B96
that's what we call the p96 I think we
had 104.3 kiss at a certain point Didn't
we 101.9 103.5 103 yes 103.5 yeah yeah
and it was 97.1 but you should have
known WGCI 1075 that's like Southside
well we never listened to it but I we
know about it yeah never car about that
one I'm just to start it was
always3 we would always switch between
the mix and Q and A1 because those are
the only ones that played music that
were enjoyable oh
B96
what else is there I don't know B96 was
just like random dance so I love that
you'd put it on it
like and you're like okay that's cool
but you know if I want to sing you know
fast ball the way I got to put on q01
yes I used to record onto cassette and
bounc C on other Cass time to be alive
it was like on those like dual cassette
it was like those amfm like um mixtap uh
like the alarm clocks I would like take
my mom's and I would like record it and
like yeah yeah the DJ would talk over
the beginning song like stop all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and share the
show with your friends I guess we're
going to talk about the true nature that
is Taylor Swift and the dark conspiracy
because uh well the the the real story
is the end of times is coming and
there's a lot of people talking about
the holy land and the Great War in
Jerusalem or whatever but I guess we'll
throw Taylor Swift into the mix we'll
talk about that in the members only show
so go to
timcast.net personally at timcast Grace
do you want to shout anything out yes
definitely um join timcast.net
and also um uh go for the the app I'm
like forgetting about it it's um Bill
Blaster
app.org and war.org
and uh yeah follow me on Twitter gc22 GC
bannon's war room follow us on all the
platforms and thank you so much um it's
been great so fun having yeah it's been
great being here thank you so much I
love merch and I love your sweatshirt oh
yes exced shop War Room LLC 20% off
timcast 20 that's the dis discount code
oh my gosh have to buy some stuff yes
I'm Hannah CL brimo I'm a writer for
timcast.net and Instagram or if you like
our website you can click on the read
Tab and see all the work from me Adrian
Norman Chris burtman occasionally Shane
uh Cassandra McDonald and the other
people I can't remember now uh if you
want to follow me personally I'm on
Instagram at Hanah Clair Duppy and I'm
on Twitter at HC brimo guys thank you so
much yeah I'm Shane Cashman you can
check out the latest invert world book
at ghost ofthe civil war.com I'm
probably going to go to Maine and go WR
about what's going on up there I've been
talking we're taking a trip to Maine I'm
in I think I have to uh it's been I've
been uh dismayed over what's going on up
there and talking a lot of friends who
know people who lost people so that's
probably next uh for me but it's been
being here with you and I'm surge.com I
misspoke in the beginning of the show we
already beat England so I was trying to
say we were celebrating the W from Eng
yeah we're celebrating the win over
England and we're going to face uh the
All Blacks in New Zealand you didn't
even know how much of in New Zealand but
yeah anyways cheers guys all right
everybody we'll see you all over at
timcast.net